e
all
right so it's now 10 o'clock we will um
open this work session on the Department
of Business and economics affairs
and who are we welcoming
today okay
um so feel we are going to be um it's
page 519 through 537 but let's start on
537 just to get the big
picture okay
thank you so please introduce yourself
uh good morning my name is Chase Hegman
I'm the director of the division of
business division of economic
development at BDA and I'm joined by my
colleague Kathy good morning Mr chair
members of the committee Kathy
Frederickson Director of Finance
Department of Business Administration
thank you for allowing us this
opportunity to speak with you today
great
okay so you you gave us a lot of stuff
here or maybe that wasn't you I don't
know
sbbc operating budget okay here we
go
um maybe we so what do we have we have
an
hour
um
so I think we we saw most of this
structure type stuff in our previous
meeting right yes we did so maybe we can
go straight to to um straight to budget
questions just kind of go through the
pages does that make sense yeah so when
don't we start at the end
um you have um 78 positions for for
unclassified um are any of those uh
vacant
unfunded um at this is this on yes okay
at this time we do have a couple of
positions that are vacant but we do have
a a strategic plan for those positions
um we have a senior planner position
that is vacant currently we are seeking
a waiver from the governor's office
because it has um that position has FEMA
requirements it will be
um right now we have it in the budget as
100% generally funded but we do have we
recently learned that we have the
opportunity to have that position up to
36% reimbursed from federal funds um
under the FEMA requirements
we do also have a program assistant
position that is vacant but it's um and
that one is 100% federal funds under the
orid
program we have a program specialist
position that is vacant as well at this
time we
are as part of the reorganization
process for the division of um planning
and Community Development we will be
looking to seek to reclass classify that
position as the
um
the pl office of planning's
supervisor and we have um I'm sorry yes
we have the two housing Champions
positions those positions were
authorized in this current bium but they
were not funded this bium we're looking
to fund those two positions in 2627
because we were in the implementation
phase of housing champions um in this
bium and in the next bium we expect it
to be the the program Administration to
occur so we will be meing those
positions to run the program are they
funded in here they in this budget
request they are funded yes okay but
they're vacant they're vac currently
because we don't have they're not funded
in this by and you're under the freeze
right so yes yeah
okay and then we do have um we do have a
listing of temporary positions as well
that um
are not um filled at this time we do
have we do have a waiver to advertise
for a couple of them at this time and
those are for the welcome centers those
are filled as uh budget funds allow in
class 50 okay great Mr chair if I might
add go ahead um just to sort of
reiterate what Kathy was sharing um the
vacant positions are typically related
to specific programs and as those
programs evolve the need for that
position may change or increase over
time gotcha okay now in general you're
looking for another 3.3 million of
General funds compared to the previous
banum
um is there kind of a big picture place
where most of those are
going yeah did you want to speak for
that thank you Mr chair thank you
members of the committee for the
question uh those funds relate
specifically or largely to um the
division of travel and tourism
development uh the increase in funding
relative to what the agency had
presented uh is um what the governor
hased proposed based off of the uh what
has historically been viewed as the
formula that derives the funding for
that division so the the funding there
would go to Industry promotion and
support a variety of programs and
marketing efforts that uh run through
that division that wasn't there
previously uh it it was not permitted to
be there previously because of a
regulatory change that had occurred um
that we actually weren't aware of at the
time but uh in working with Das provided
what was required of US during the
agency
um proposal and now with the governor's
proposal sort of restoring that no I
meant compared to the current B oh yeah
in terms of actual spend yeah yes well
it's not just actual right on page
537 um adjusted authorized for fiscal
year 25 is even less than
actual in uh 24 right so correct and
that and sorry apologies so and and from
both of those numbers it's up 3 point
something yeah correct and that is um
based on how the formula that derives
the revenue for travel and tourism is
calculated it's typically 3.15% of the
net of meals and rooms tax uh Revenue so
this would just be a continuation of the
use of that formula to get to that level
so it's not um it's based on how the
funding could be used uh based on the
historic um standard for that formula
gotcha okay all right well why don't we
go back to the beginning and we'll just
go kind of section by section um and see
what's happening in each one so page
[Music]
okay all
right so were any of these two
unclassified part year or something like
that I apologize Mr chair the the budget
on our table is not numbered in terms of
page number so I at the yeah look at the
top oh at the very top yeah so this is
you you your start of your this is
Office of the
commissioner there are two unclassified
positions correct um in the office of
the commissioner so the unclassified
positions would be commissioner Caswell
and then the other unclassified position
would be the addition of the um
intergovermental intergovernmental
Affairs position so that position was
not there previously gotcha okay all
right so that's new okay so one is
new is it now filled though yes yeah yes
that would be um Genie Forester gotcha
all right um the next
page um it
says uh what is um the source of funds
agency indirect cost recoveries what
does that mean those are the um indirect
cost recoveries for federal funds
they're associated with federal funds so
those are the F those are the recovery
for the recovery funds for the federal
funds where um we're paying back um
funds to D for doing all of the overhead
costs associated with um managing
Federal programs I see so so because the
commissioner part of their job is
federal dealing with the federal
programs you get to corre to take a
little from the I because everything
that occurs in the commissioner's office
we can't designate to a direct program I
can't you know like um office of
Workforce Development is federally
funded and they're very specific to a
specific program but because when my
department the business office is
working on a program what we do when
we're booking the invoices we're working
for every single program in the agency
so it's done through our the cost of us
is done through an indirect cost
recovery okay all right now on page 520
um so now we're starting the rest areas
and you you have the rest areas in two
groups one's associated with Turnpike
and the other is not correct right so um
tell us about just the in general how
many rest areas in each how many people
uh use the facility ities things like
that okay so um is that in your
presentation somewhere the there are 12
rest areas
um the Au 2176 is the
turnpike and that is the hooks at North
and southbound and Seabrook and then the
other um rest areas are generally funded
those are the ones that were listed by
commissioner Caswell the last time we
were here and then we did provide foot
counts last time we were here so um
Canterbury coldbrook Intervale Lebanon
Littleton Salem Sanbornton Springfield
and Sutton would be the ones that are
generally funded and between all 12 um
rest areas we did provide a foot count
of 5.8 million in FY
well that's for all 12 yes got you
go ahead representative wer how many of
these are seasonal and how many are year
round at this particular time all
welcome centers were open year round I
didn't note that when I've stopped at
some we us actually I apologize Sutton
is closed currently but all the the rest
the remainder of the welcome centers are
open
Sutton if I might add Mr chair go ahead
um just uh noting and I don't know if
this made it your way but the hours of
operation are typically 9 to5 UM Salem
is 8 to 10 seab Brook is 24 hours uh
which is a a slight change from preco
when most of them were open 8 to eight
or or longer hours so as a result of
budget changes over that time and um
adapting to you know changes in the bvs
budget some of the uh locations have had
to reduce their
hours so there's only like 14 full-time
employees in this area right or is that
just for the rate for the non turnpike
so the four Time full the 14 full-time
positions are under the general funds
there's an additional 11 under Turnpike
okay so there's 25 and there must be a
lot of temps too right there are there
are a a large number of temps in both
areas
okay um could it um could it be shifted
more towards
temps so in in speaking with the
operations manager for that area it
would be very difficult to do that
because typically when he's doing the
scheduling what he tries to do is have
one full-time person on per shift so at
all times when the welcome center is
open there's typically one full-time
person who would be a super Bas
essentially a supervisor for the center
and then it's sub the out the Staffing
is subsidized with the part-time people
got okay all right good so let's go to
page
523 outdoor recreation
um so there's two people what do these
do at this particular
no that that was mentioned um by Kathy
that referenced orid the outdoor
recreation industry development uh so we
have one currently one dedicated staff
member that uh focuses exclusively on
that industry um within broader uh
strategies and
efforts and it's all fed looks
correct
okay all right and what are they doing I
mean oh all manner of things so they uh
engage businesses that uh are part of or
support the outdoor recreation industry
they're engaged in um trade shows and
large scale events effectively marketing
and supporting what we have available in
New Hampshire and ensuring that those
businesses have the support and
assistance they need to navigate
whatever issues or challenges they have
gotcha go ahead representative evil um
hi and I apologize for being late uh the
roads were unbelievable yeah um anyway
so the federal funding I guess one
question was have you had any problem
with it in the last couple of months but
the other question is what is the source
is this a grant that you apply for
what's the funding for this position do
you know uh sorry so we have not had
problems with receiving reimbursements
from this program at this time and um
I'm in regular Communications with the
agency that administers this right now
the funding is coming from USDA and we
still have two rounds left to spend um
however the funding source is going to
be changing and we are working on that
now but we anticipate continual funding
for this program without
issue all right now we're going to page
um we skip over turnike rest areas we
cover that
525 um Economic
Development right where's the toward the
bottom there
um there's a big jump in the cost of um
the
uh there's one unclassified position so
was that only filled part year or is
this somehow somebody's getting a big
raise or what Mr chair you're looking at
the
that's him so this my position the
director role was unfilled um for a
little while and thus the budget was
reduced at that time we filled the role
and it now accounts for my salary okay
great and um what's going on with dues
organizational dues that's more than
doubling so that's uh in large part a
result of our participation in the
northern borders Regional Commission so
the state um has to contribute a certain
amount of administrative funding for the
uh for mbrc itself itself as an entity
that's sort of our cost of participation
and the overall program which provides
millions of dollars in Grants to um
entities around the state in our our
mostly rural areas uh so the jump here
is simply um an effort to try and better
budget for those dues they often hit
relative to the federal um fiscal year
and it doesn't always align well with
our state fiscal year so this is in part
trying to better stratey that and there
has been a slight increase but I think
Kathy had more to say yeah the
additional comment to that so that does
we are statutorily required to pay in
the program it's shared between four
states in New England and the reason why
you're seeing that bump in class 26 is
because previously it was incorrectly
coded in class one 102 and it is now
correctly coded in uh class 26 and that
was um that was a correction that was
done in conjunction with um Das
so you said that there's a lot of grants
in this area do we see them in on the
page somewhere or
no um if they are not federally if
they're federally funded but not
budgeted no you wouldn't see them but
you would see um uh our office of
Workforce opportunity which um receives
about what $14 million annually to run
uh training and upskilling programs in
partnership with other agencies we also
have an apex accelerator program which
is uh focused on um helping local
businesses engage in Government
Contracting and having direct technical
assistance as part of that process so
those two are coming
later uh no the uh those yeah they're
already in here no the 14 million for
the office of Workforce opportunity is
in here is is in is within the DED
budget okay so we'll come to it I guess
is that yeah okay
all right
um now also in your group is uh another
100,000 for marketing how about that so
uh the marketing funding is critically
important for what we do as as a a
division uh especially in light of some
recent um strategies we've and reports
we've rolled out and developed a key
element of those strategies is better
promoting specific growth industries
across Ross the state uh to help with uh
recruitment efforts expansion efforts
Workforce challenges um trying to bring
the workforce we need into the state and
also bringing awareness to um different
Industries so that we can help address
supply chain needs uh and different
needs of businesses as they grow so it's
effectively um targeted funding uh
specifically for economic development as
opposed to uh travel and tourism so we
talked about travel and tourism earlier
having specific promotion and marketing
uh this a is a very small piece of the
pie for economic development specific uh
relative to uh industry growth and and
assessment so you hadn't been doing it
before it's something that we've had in
the past and we didn't have in the last
budget and we felt that it really needed
to be there this cycle it was something
that we felt was was lacking uh in our
efforts
okay all right um yes sorry represent W
what effect did we see by not having
this program
well this um it's a great question
representative it's it's not a specific
program it's simply a line item that
would would enable enable us to use
dollars specifically for marketing and
promotion relative to specific indri
Industries so I would say one thing we
were unable to do was um engage in
specific advertising or promotion of say
our Advanced manufacturing Industries or
Life Sciences things that are industries
that are seeing a lot of growth and
attention uh that we could really be a
partner and helping support that growth
it seems like we've had this before and
if we took it away was there a big
difference
and I yes the short answer the big
difference comes from uh what our team
and what our division feels they're able
to do in terms of supporting the
industry which is part of our role and
expected of us in many respects so it's
not just tourism it's trying to lure
businesses to this state no the division
of Economic Development has a specific
recruitment team so we we have um a
staff that's focused on Business
Development so recruitment into the
state and then a staff that's focused on
um business resources which is helping
those that are already here expand grow
um tackle different challenges uh and we
felt um we've been a little bit
hamstrung I think on the business
recruitment side because we didn't have
this in the budget last go
around I didn't notice any difference
thank
you okay um all right so now we're going
into
into uh procurement here page
527 all this is related to
federal grants for the most part
although now you're adding a bunch of
General funds to
this on page
528 so there's an extra
person which one's
145 oh so Apex sorry uh so this refers
to the Apex accelerator program that I
previously mentioned that program
requires um a state contribution uh to
receive the federal funds and run the
program itself so we um provide
effectively in-kind matches relative to
salaries and rent and things of that
nature that do uh implicate the the
general funds General General Revenue
budget okay what so is this is the whole
Apex thing part this this uh section
namely 500,000 of federal and 200,000 of
state is that is that what it is yes
okay and what does it do what does what
does it mean Apex so we have a team of
three full-time staff one part-time
staff that run this program uh they are
tasked with managing um support for
Government Contracting uh specifically
Apex focuses on DOD Contracting uh but
they do
all other manner of Government
Contracting support as well but a lot of
the funding is run through in support of
DOD Contracting so they uh work with
businesses one-on-one they provide
informational webinars they do
matchmaking events they can help a
business go Soup To Nuts from I want to
apply or or on this bid to all the way
hopefully getting an award and I think
if I read the number correctly they
helped over 125 businesses last year get
about $2 billion in government contracts
okay yeah probably anyway okay so
um
contract okay page
so
um office of Workforce
opportunity so here um this is all
federal but I was just curious what
what's going on with contracts for
program Services an
extra
$4.3
million Mr chair if I recall correctly
that had more to do with um the timing
of different contracts for services as
they were uh the way that program is run
there are four or five subrecipients
that run targeted aspects of the the
training and Outreach programs and I
believe that may have just been a result
of the timing of those contracts and
when they when they went into place and
the funding for
them this entire office um is required
to engage in a multi-year strategic plan
and effort based on the specific funding
that they're awarded from the federal
government so it wouldn't be uh new
dollars here unless their award was
increased and there's a little tiny bit
of general fund here
correct any particular reason or that's
just to allow occasionally um people
within that department will support um
other areas in the agency and that that
allows money for them to support go
outside of their own
Department okay we try not to tap that
if we can't if we don't have to sure
just you just give us more detail on the
federal
funds like the sources
or oh shoot I think the source might be
um Commerce or no E I believe this is
all US Department of Commerce yeah
Commerce and the money goes to uh most
of it a large Chun of It Go chunk of it
goes to New Hampshire employment
security it goes to the cap program it
goes to my turn and it goes to Jag just
to add to that there's a coalition
basically that was formed to um
facilitate these overall this overall
program the workface workforce uh
Innovation opportunity act weoa um so
there are multiple agencies that help
facilitate the programs then there are
subrecipients that receive grants to run
specific programs um for displaced
workers or even youth programs to help
get them the training they might want to
get a new job or the upskilling they
might need to move from one uh industry
to
another and one of our hb2 items
actually addresses this particular
program it's updating all the statutory
references um um to this particular
program because the ACT that um is
regulates this has been
updated
okay all right so
now um okay so we come to now uh page
530 as far as I can tell this is like
the only cut that the governor made or
something close to that and and it's
something we're getting a lot of email
about so let's talk about that Small
Business Development
Center going from uh half a million to
215 what does that do and it's making
grants I guess or or something like that
sure so sbdc um is in our view an
incredibly important uh program within
the state that gives one-on-one
technical assistance to uh new and small
businesses around the state um from
everything from you know how to start a
business to some legal and financial
guidance based on you know a recent
Grant they received on on efforts that
they can do so uh it's not it's not
necessarily a cut that we're happy about
but when we look at the targets that we
have to hit uh it was one of the only
areas that we really felt that we even
had any room or a choice to make with
regard to that so it was a it a
difficult prioritization in terms of
what the overall mission of the agency
does and and how we're able to partner
with others so this is some kind of NGO
type of thing right ferally funded or
it's a it's a federal program that has
representation in I think every state um
so they have an entity in Sp spdc in
across the country and they have a very
defined
role I see and I think we got some a
bunch of data here right from them that
we can look at yes it's it's without
question they have an enormous impact
for sure yes go ahead representative
Griffin thank you for taking my question
U you you people apparently get a lot
lot of federal
funds how many of them or what
percentage of those funds require a
level of uh State matching any level of
State matching or is it all just free
you don't have to match any of
it you can jump on this with me but
there's it's certainly not all free
there are a few programs that require
some level of State match um the Apex
accelerator that we were just talking
about being one of them um a percentage
requirement uh but I would say as as a
result of the funding that we have
coming into the agency what less than
half of our overall budget is actually
generally funded um so we get uh For
What Little Skin we have to have in the
game to get those federal funds we're
able to do a lot with them could we get
a list of the federal funds that requ
state matching in the percentage sure
thank you absolutely all right
representative evil yes thank you just
following up on the um Small Business
Development comp I I can't imagine there
was there we haven't heard from uh on
any cut as much right now as we have on
this particular one and um I mean it
seems like the based on the emails that
we're getting from a business standpoint
it seems like the return on the
investment is huge for our state um and
so I you know I know Cuts need to be
made but I think this particular one is
maybe cutting through the muscle and
into the bone and um anyway I realize we
don't have a lot of money to throw
around but I think this one for a couple
hundred, dollar might be worth helping
out just a little bit so I don't know
just keep I'm just amazed at the at the
uh I mean can you talk about the ROI on
this a little bit more or do you want to
wait on this discussion you can go ahead
okay cuz you said there was a lot of
there kind of on on time I think so yeah
so I'm sorry am I answering the question
go ahead okay um we have this yeah so
that was actually provided by sbdc who's
in the room so I can't speak to to
what's in the folder but I absolutely
agree um each annual report that sbdc
kicks out there's um enormous bang for
the buck in terms of what they're able
to do and how many businesses they're
able to reach I think if I'm remembering
correctly they were able to engage close
to 2,000 businesses last year uh and
helpful in that regard with as you said
representative a relatively small amount
of
money
okay representative cambrell thank you
Mr chair um is the program receiving any
federal
funding I believe the answer to that
question is yes uh I believe they have a
a grant through um
ssbci um and there may be one other they
may have received about $100,000 in arpa
funding previously but I don't know if
that money is already exhausted at this
point so that would be important for us
to know how much they're getting if if
you could get that amount absolutely or
maybe if we're through with these guys a
little bit early we can ask them to come
yeah yeah I'm sorry about that and um
the other question
um are there uh currently small
businesses like waiting in line to get
loans is there a waiting list for this
uh for these uh assistance I'm not aware
of a waiting list but if we're going to
bring spdc up at some point after this
it might be a better question to ask
them okay and I will just add sorry if I
may follow up real quick representative
just add that um you know like with
anything if spdc does receive federal
funding which I believe they do it's
probably for a very specific purpose so
it's not necessarily generally
applicable there may be a specific
program that they're running that they
support with those
funds all right so next on page 530 what
is capacity
Grant um the capacity grant that relates
to the nbrc program that we mentioned
earlier the northern B northern border
Regional Commission the capacity Grant
is the federal funding the state
receives to administratively run that
program um within the state so there is
a staff person uh dedicated to
overseeing
mbrc and uh helping facilitate multiple
program rounds for you know application
rounds for for programs helping provide
technical assistance and then also uh
overseeing um uh a contractor that
that's supports the technical assistance
overall gotcha and those are all federal
funds gotcha yeah all right so now we're
going to travel and
tourism and U page
um so let's see here sorry 532 532
um so there's Marketing in a couple of
different ways here um there's uh
promotional marketing
expense and then there's um Grant
subsidies and
relief right and then later on um we're
going to see um
what oh at the bottom of the page
promotional marketing
expense
um or is that the same no that's
different so what's the difference
between line 69 in accounting unit uh
203 and what we see at the bottom of the
page they're basically categorized
categorized differently based on the
type of recipient and the program that
is being um awarded
out yeah so if I may follow up it's just
a
a budgeted amount based on how the
funding is likely to be used so if we um
I'll give an example the uh Grant
subsidies and relief that you mentioned
that's called The Joint that that
supports that money is used for the
joint promotional program which is a
grant program so we would issue grants
um through that specific line in in in
our accounting system versus having it
all pulled in one generic and we we
break it out based on the class and how
it'll be used
okay so both of these are going up
substantially right so
um one is up uh looks like 990,000 the
next one 250,000 the next one 2
million
yes all right um and I I'll just speak
to you know I I mentioned the joint
promotional program uh that's going up
proposed to go up to 1.25 million that's
an incredibly successful program where
um grants are given typically to
Chambers or different trade associations
for um promotional events across the
state like bike week or restaurant week
or the seafood festival uh and it's it's
a way for us to um partner with those
tourism related efforts and support and
lower some of the cost to entry to even
have those events so it's often an over
subscribed program uh so we're budgeting
for an increase in it so that we can
you're talking about grants yes okay yes
what about
marketing uh which line 69 well 69 and
the other 69
both which other
69 okay right you have 69 in the middle
of the page and you have 69 right at the
bottom of the page oh sorry I my the
fold of my pages uh so the if I
understand correctly the 69 at the
bottom of the page would be largely
where we uh would concentrate um the
tourism focused advertising and
promotion funding that we talked a bit
earlier about the formula change and the
increase in funding for how it' be used
a lot of it would be put there so that
it could be used for broader marketing
campaigns which are often pretty
expensive but have to be so this is tv
ads and things like that what's that TV
ads uh print uh online TV um video I
mean when you when you look at and you
may have seen this in our our followup
um from the last presentation but um
there's actually a pretty phenomenal
return on investment for use of these
funds it's one of the only funds that we
can take meals and and and rooms tax
revenue and help generate substantially
more Revenue by the number of tourists
were're able to bring in as a result of
this highly effective um promotion and
marketing I have a feeling that when you
do this
return on investment you're saying we
spent this we and the total amount of
tourism in New Hampshire is that and you
say one is creating from the other right
I mean I don't
see H have you done experiments where
this number gets smaller and therefore
that number got smaller yeah yes so I
apologize um there is a a contractor
that travel and tourism works with to
derive the ROI number it's not just
pulled out of a thin air they they
interview um tourist they create a an
econom a model for it and are able to co
this is a professor at Plymouth
yes no this the the SM report that we
provided to you as followup from our
last testimony that's the company now
that company works with uh approximately
25 States across the country so they are
very well-versed in providing these
types of studies it's also important to
note that the the people that they are
surveying are all people who are
visiting our state they're not residents
of our state so the return on investment
um you know our travel and tourism
department wants us to be aware that
these are funds they don't believe would
actually come into our state if not for
spending this money because when they're
doing these studies they're going out
and if they've advertised in a test
market like New York City for example
they're they're advertising New York
City they're now going out and they're
they're doing doing their study in New
York City to determine what the return
on investment in that advertising was so
you came to our state now and youve
spent this money how much did you spend
in order to determine the the ROI and so
now they believe the the study is saying
that this money would not have been
spent here because now they would have
seen an ad and they would have gone to
Florida instead they would have gone to
California so so the belief is that this
money would not have come into our state
if not for these this advertising
advertising being spent and that's why
it's considered so important and I will
just add that it is it is a highly
competitive environment a lot of States
invest a decent amount of funding in
this kind of promotion and so retracting
from that or regressing from that and
based on what Kathy just said and what
you see in some of these reports could
have a negative impact on the amount of
meals and rooms tax revenue that comes
in I get all right any other questions
on this area no okay um let's move on to
let's see get
planning so page
533 uh planning and Community
Development so what is going on with
this
so is this Regional planning is this
something
else so we're talking about the whole
division so the division of planning and
Community Development uh is also part of
what you see in um the reorganization
and hb2 uh some of the language you have
there uh what it does is it pulls three
um different not different but three
related areas of focus for the agency so
we have the uh office of Planning and
Development uh which um has existed with
Bea for a few years now uh that focuses
on Municipal level um uh technical
assistance mapping uh helping uh assess
land use regulations and make
recommendations with communities as they
work with them uh then we also have the
other two teams that are being added
into this division um which focus on
housing so they run oversee the invest
and H program and the housing Champions
program and then we have a Broadband
team um that is in here as well uh that
focuses on the Broadband infrastructure
buildout that is underway so those three
groups or three offices are brought
together under under the division of
planning and Community Development where
this was previously just the office of
Planning and Development within baa
question representative W isn't there a
lot of overlap with the regional
planning
commissions it's a great question I
would say no because our staff uh focus
focuses in specifically on uh the the
needs of municipalities and partnering
with other uh entities like the regional
planning commissions and the municipal
Association so there isn't typically a
lot of overlap but there is a lot of
coordination and
collaboration thank you representative
evil hi I'm I realize so this is the
this is the department is it right it
was once a division and now you want to
make it an office or something so it was
this the one this is the one okay yeah
this is the one so this is an office
that would now be one of three offices
within a division okay so previously uh
the divisions at Bea were Economic
Development and travel and tourism this
is a third formal division pulling those
three offices together because um
although there's not not a lot of
overlap in what they do there's a lot of
uh ability to um work together and and
collaborate and coordinate efforts and
then sort of cross collaborate as a team
internally so if you've got our housing
program that's housing Champions that's
working with uh communities with
infrastructure projects or um permitting
units um our office of Planning and
Development can be a resource as well
for that program staff but also the
communities that are engaging in those
programs the same can be said about
Broad
okay so some of the structural changes
that we see in hb2 they're not so much
really structural changes it's just kind
of a shifting around correct yes okay
and then um so on the draft of hb2 that
we have which you probably don't have
it's page 43 there's $5 million in here
for the housing Champion program yes so
is that in hb1 or is this new spending
so I can answer but you can double down
it but that $5 billion already exists
based off of the previous legislative
session all this does in hb2 is extend
the time for the funding to be used so
it previously sunsetted June 30th of
2025 the end of this fiscal year uh and
we're extending it seeking to extend it
until the end of next year uh just
because none of it has been spent it's
or knit next to it is answering the
question delicately it's not that it
hasn't been spent it's that the last
year to year and a half there was a lot
of setup that had to be done for those
programs including going through the
administrative uh rulemaking process uh
the housing Champions program itself has
a staff member we're certainly utilizing
that funding the initial application
round has already run there were 18
communities that were designated housing
Champions and now those 18 communities
can apply for two different programs
that I believe are currently open for
application
uh which frankly will draw at the result
of those applications will likely take
up all the funding for the program uh
but there is a little bit of concern
that if we need to run an additional
round of the program that we wouldn't be
able to do that before the end of June
so this is more of a a play of sort of
taking a cautionary approach to make
sure um we can adequately run that
program so where does that $5 million
show up in your budget or is it some
it's already on our stat it's already on
our statement of Appropriations
currently okay so it would just be a
carry forward amount because it was a
2425 thing correct is there a 26 27
similar appropriation or no not at this
time okay but yet you're keeping the the
office right the housing Champions
office on page
535 is still there so well the program
itself there um there are two programs
that are run there's the housing
Champions program and now a state funded
invest and age program um then there's
also the reality that the housing
Champions program is a multi-year
program that will also require oversight
of of the projects that are given uh
grant funding so the housing Champion
designation is on a three-year cycle and
then uh we run multiple application
rounds a year for more and more
communities to become designated housing
Champions so even if
we chew up all $5 million in this award
round there's still a lot of
administrative work and oversight that
needs to be done on the program itself
it's why the office would need to
continue okay so uh is the RSA noted
here in association with the
Appropriations I I just wanted to check
the um statutory structure of the
housing
Champions program I don't know if it's
mentioned in the hb2 language it's I
just see 79 colon 46 the LBA can yeah I
mean it's in our it's in Ba's RSA 12-
statute is in that
structure
okay okay and now um Broadband so this
is all federal looks like is that
right or mostly yes go ahead
represent first let me apologize for
being late it was a slippery ride we
understand uh just going back to the
housing that's obviously been a major
concern of the executive branch and
legislative branch so did you put any
request in for additional monies on top
of the five million that's kind of left
over so there'd be more money available
for 26 and 27 should that five money
five million be
expended I'd be hesitant to speak on
behalf of the commissioner or our
director of intergovernmental Affairs
but I know that the team has worked with
legislators as they've come forward with
interest in putting funding into those
programs I don't know the status of of
that legislation though but you're not
aware of any request that was made by
your department to get additional money
correct we didn't proactively say please
give us this amount of money for this
program okay thanks thanks Mr chair that
I'm aware of okay yeah that's fine
thanks let see have a correction of that
all right so they they were hb2 items
last time so we were not allowed to put
it in agency budget so Broadband you got
a new um Federal grant is
that yes so Broadband is um complicated
Beast uh all federal funding but
different sources of federal funds so
there's uh what's currently being built
out right now through the American
Rescue plan act capital projects fund uh
the state received about 122 million
dollars there uh to build out Broadband
infrastructure access and build out
Broadband infrastructure and provide
access to unserved and underserved
locations based off of FCC Maps so
there's currently um two major build
outs underway that'll bring over 50,000
households or locations access to
high-speed internet and then uh then
what we're coming up on is the um what's
called The Bead program and it's another
about $191 million um you don't see
numbers of that magnitude in here that's
just the big picture uh the money that
we've received um because those programs
are on a draw down typically relate to
administrative costs and running the
program and setting it up uh with the
exception of the arpa funding that's
already all um obligated and being spent
out are you saying $100 million in New
Hampshire yes yes is being spent on this
kind of thing yes I
see representative I remember an Alec
conference where they talked about it
was almost a billion coming to New
Hampshire that was like two years ago
and hardly anything has happened
Broadway interesting okay all right so
go ahead yes we did talk about this
program at the last presentation where
we've already received $5 million on
this and there's another $191 million
allocation it was included in the
follow-up presentation provided and so
this is an estimate of the
administrative costs expected and then
we are actually currently looking to
bring um $12 million in right now
because as the next allocation into
fiscal and this will help sustain the
office um so that we we can um
effectively run the office in the next
budget cycle and there's still more
money to be brought in if I may add Mr
chair yeah go ahead so one thing to add
on to what Kathy was saying and the
reason why I called it a bit complicated
at the outset wasn't to diminish our
ability to understand it but to point
out that it is federally regulated and
there are defined steps in the process
so the office has had to develop several
multi-year plans on how they're going to
use the funding uh where it's going to
be um awarded and they're amidst final
steps of of doing that so they've had to
do uh to get approval on two major plans
and then they have to run a whole
application program that will lay that
will identify who is actually getting
money from that $191 million and once
that is complete then we have to get
approval of it so it's not unfortunately
it's not a a quick injection or use of
funding it's a multi-year process that's
pretty when you say the office I don't
see any people here so it's somewhere
else so the the staff is fully federally
funded correct yeah so we had there
are four I believe they're currently
paid out of an off-budget Broadband
account correct they're n 9t positions
yeah oh so there's a dedicated fund yes
yes okay all right so we'll we'll take a
look at that maybe all right
anyways okay very
good okay four people so this is the end
of
um uh Bea do we have other question
Bea yeah I mean this is it I know the
commissioner's not here so yeah all
right representative all I was going to
say on the housing Champions I didn't
notice it when we're talking about it
but it's on page 534 down at the bottom
there it talks about the admin
administrative expense I think that we
were talking about just so you see where
it
is yeah right right it they they started
a little yeah this year and then and
then there's more ongoing yeah um and I
actually I know Mike Li Liberty I know
he's been really involved in the
broadband and he's really um excited
about the progress that you guys are
making and you know if you have to
develop plans it shows that they're
expending funds carefully right exactly
and we're if I might add we're our goal
is 100% access across the state with
these funds so we're well well on our
way to
that
okay yeah so we have about five minutes
we can talk is is this Miss gray who's
here all right come on up
definitely should take the governor's
budget thank you so your name is my name
is Jason Canon I'm the associate state
director for the
spdc okay so what can you tell us about
what you
do um what I do or what the organization
the organization um so the sbdc program
is a program that's um been around for
over 45 years it was created by the
small business act there's a Small
Business Development Center in every
state in US Territory so there's
63 um around the country um it's
federally funded based on a population
funding formula and that funding does
require State match so here in New
Hampshire we receive uh this current
year almost $800,000 from the federal
government which does require a match of
which this 50 or um yes 50 50% has to be
cash 50% can be in in kind um and this
state funding is a large portion of that
match okay and what do you do with the
money I'm sorry what do you do with
these funds with these funds so
specifically the funds from the state
every dollar from the state goes right
into paying for business advisors that
help small businesses so um we have
about 14 business advisors the of about
10 full you know FTE some of them are
part-time um and they work around the
state helping small businesses um
everything from I have an idea and I
want to start a business to exit
strategies it could be resiliency
planning business planning marketing
cyber security a lot on cyber security
um right
now so and we were actually in the last
five years demand for those Services has
gone up over 120% in five years
okay so is it something like score is
that it's a little bit different score
is volunteers um so they're they're
retired um people who used to work in uh
in business not necessarily small
businesses um all of our advisers are go
through a certification process they all
have experience owning a business
running a business they all have
mbas um they do professional development
but all of our services are at no cost
to taxpayers I see so if one more
question then I'll let represent Camal
so you said there are 14 of them for yes
14 total some are part-time some are
full-time there's about 10 full-time
equivalents so if the governor's budget
went through presumably it would go down
to seven or something like that yes we
would lose three full-time business
advisers about 30% of our advising
capacity um at a time when we're seeing
historic numbers of small businesses
looking for assistance gotcha all right
thank you representative camell thank
you Mr chair uh uh does have you ever do
you always spend all the money every
year or so there's no rolling over
there's no current balance in the fund
no there is not no we we we get it for
two years and we typically spend it down
by the end each year spend it down by
the end of the the year so currently
your balance would be zero or uh yes
whatever is left for this current year
we would have thank you representative
Sweeney thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here to take our questions I
guess let's say in in the absence of
sbdc would it then fall to the the banks
or to like Chambers of Commerce to um
I'm not sure because they refer their
clients to us yeah um we get a lot lot
of referrals from banks for people that
are looking to get Capital but they
don't have a business plan ready so we
have a lot of Partners in Banks Chambers
we work very closely with um a lot of
the big Chambers and the small Chambers
they send a lot of clients to us um
especially during Co they were getting
calls you know from businesses they know
what to do and they were calling us cuz
we were the ones that were answering the
phone so I'm not sure they would either
have to go to another provider like
score which you know would kind of
overwhelm I assume overwhelm uh their
capacity um or they would have to pay
for those Services if they
could representative evil thank you Mr
chair so just getting back to my return
on investment question um and just
taking a survey of the amazing number of
emails enthusiastic emails that we've
gotten um could you just talk a little
bit
about your assessment of how much
support and how successful your program
is sure we've um there's a couple of
different measures there's one um we
have a National Association that does an
annual study to determine that uh return
on investment and they have determined
that every dollar invested in an sbdc
program returns back $10 um in in tax
revenue um here in New Hampshire we
worked with an economist at the
University of New Hampshire to develop a
metric to determine um what that annual
impact is on the economy it's based on
um jobs created jobs save business
starts Capital infusion um along with um
and New Hampshire employment security
data of average wages um and for the
current year the impact that the sbdc
has is over $245 million on the
economy re people so I mean I guess I
asked that question and I know
everything's being cut pretty tight but
like I look at the $700 billion
marketing program you could take2 200 or
$250,000 from that which would be a very
small portion of it and fund it in a way
that it seems an awful lot of small
business folks would like to see it
and maybe it's one television ad in the
market
thing I mean I don't I don't know how
much that would really Buy in the in the
in the world of marketing but it's seems
to me that this is a really meaningful
program to an awful lot of people I I
would agree it's a relatively small
amount and just that amount of money the
275,000 um three business advisers were
talking probably two to 300 small
businesses that wouldn't be assisted you
know a few thousand hours of advising
hundreds of jobs that are not created or
saved millions of dollars that are not
infused into small businesses whether
it's Equity Capital owner investment
loans SBA and non SBA backed um and
probably a couple dozen small businesses
not
started thank you thank you all right um
so I think we're can I just get your
name for the record again it's Jason
Canon
C all right we are going to move on on
to
das I believe is that right yes
um
page um
yeah and I was
H yeah we're going to start on page
101 I think which is the end of this
group
here well yeah that's their attached
agencies their real end is on
101 all right so yeah that's fine okay
[Music]
yeah
so so how's your wife Mr commissioner um
please turn on
you she uh uh it's probably a fractured
kneecap not a broken but what that means
is you can't move it or it will break
which means she can't move which is
awkward cuz um she's a full-time
caretaker for Henry oh and she can't
move so I'm rning around this morning
like cooking and getting clothes out and
like trying to sort things out and go
all right here say a lunch here and he
can heat it up and then I'll be back
later I have to go get yelled at by a
bunch of legislators so will she be in
the cast or um it's funny they have her
in like one of those things that's like
a brace and I think she wants a cast cuz
she's scared to death of bending sure
and so I don't know we'll see but we
were it's funny because I went and
picked her up last night and um we're
coming out of like conquered Ortho acute
whatever it's called and uh so I hold a
door for her and then the guy behind her
who's Jim Basset on the Supreme
Court it's a and a neighbor of ours so
it's a bad day for
Canterbury I have to say I snapped my
kneecap in half this summer so you you
if she can maintain it at fracture level
and not break um it's worth
doing that's good to know thank you for
that yeah well it was a granite step
that got me I thought it was a very New
Hampshire
injury I think it is
okay all right
so
um we have here let's go to page
101 uh
um the department of administrative
services so this is
an I mean this looks very excellent on
the on the paper um uh General funds
declining from 75 million in fiscal year
2024 to 61 in
2026 but I'll I'll say that there's a
little bit of a cheat here because
there's a 21 million doll land
acquisition in
2024 so so there is some increase um
except for
that oh no absolutely we in fact we were
talking about that in the hallway that
that that's the source of the increase
and it comes up a lot uh um in the
accounting system actual so the actual
expense line includes anything including
things that weren't part of the budget
that are added to it and and we had to
buy we had byy a building so so that
does in fact make it look so what do we
buy for 21 million oh uh Granite Place
Granite place where doj is now so we'll
have a place to have the legislature for
are we going to be next year next year
my understanding is that Terry has all
kinds of things going on with that and
you would really want to ask him oh
that's nice how about that okay I all
right so
[Music]
um so of the um 330 people people we see
here tell us about vacancies and so let
if I can and I'll I'll explain so um
Sher will have passed out to you two
things to try to make this piece easier
um one the second thing which looks like
this is actually this same document with
lines and
Deltas so it's it shows the change and
it's easier to read and and we
highlighted anything over 100 Grand
change um not that we can't talk about
everything else but with thought that
might make it easier CU rumor is that's
what you want to talk about is lines
that changed the other thing on that
handout if you notice for example you're
looking at the very front page um it'll
say on the kind of dead center page 55
yep that's the exact same page reference
as in your big house bill one so we
literally took everything from there
just added the change between the two
years so you could easily see the you
didn't have to do the math on the Fly
because our accting units be have about
50 pages so we added that but those page
references match exactly to your book
and same layout format so it would be a
be able to go through that so we can
highlight of those sides and then at the
very bottom of the slide can you do this
for the whole
[Laughter]
book it might take a
while just that would be easy to kind of
draw your eye and we you know can go
through that um afterwards but as
Charlie mentioned we put together a it's
a very short presentations about 10
slides um we wanted to walk through that
first because there's three that just
talk about positions and they're sort of
the first three and then we have some
high level dollars before we get into
the detail all right so I'll let you do
that okay okay so page one is a title
page two is is the graph I'm so proud of
I mean we went down 7% everybody else
went up 40 right and I'm not going to
stop saying that um but then uh to show
you what happened in the in the agency
and governor phase um from our from
where we were in 25 which was down seven
we went down another four which means
we're you know down 11 from 2019 but
then 27 obviously goes up um a bit
although we're still well down from 19
um and Sherry has called out in a giant
bubble um what those increases are 3.2
is retire Health one is the step and
salary increases that are natural with
benefits so positions you want us to
know about positions as long as we're on
this tell me about retiree Health what
what do we what are we obligated for
this is basically um Medicare Advantage
is that what it is or
it's I mean Medicare Advantage is the
delivery mechanism for how we cover
retire our Medicare retirees right so
but the law um provides for a retire
health benefit plan establishes
eligibility and further says that it may
must be operated by Das Within the funds
appropriated by the legislature so
that's that's what the obligation is is
it only state employees is it municipals
it is it is only state employees and
they must meet years of State service
requirements and those were tightened up
by the legislature beginning in in 2009
and age requirements as well okay
representative wer one of my retired
friends tells me this reduction is
Caroline and they're doing a lousy job
that's why that's reduced um so I think
they're separate things counselor um
representative uh we certainly the
savings that we achieved in the chart
that um I think it's in your package too
but we we looked at it last time we were
here if you recall it's BEC it's because
we went to Medicare Advantage and we
leveraged Federal funding right um and
that obviously has been very very good
for the State of New Hampshire and for
retirees
um Caroline's poor performance to me is
a separate issue we go out to bid we um
Anthem won the bid for both medical
coverage and Pharmacy coverage and I
explained to this to you folks when we
were last here we didn't know that they
had started their own PBM and we further
didn't know that they really weren't
ready okay and that's the kind of stuff
that companies do and Pull and that's
what we had to manage our way through
and we have and we're back back to uh
sort of level set at least he hasn't
complained to me lately yeah but but he
was right to complain I have complained
too by the way and he should also feel
free to complain to us we have a office
that's there for that um the other thing
I I want to add the savings aren't just
that um the initial savings were
generated in part by deciding to go to
Medicare Advantage
for medical not prescription the car on
Pieces Just when we rolled prescription
in a year ago and and not that it wasn't
horrible but it was horrible so anyway
so that that's retire Health okay but
there's no savings unlike pensions right
where there's savings that pay for that
there's nothing here for that right I
mean it's it's pay as you go it's a it's
a just a benefit right but it's a
benefit to people who worked for us a
long time ago
um or maybe last year or maybe in
December yeah yeah yeah but it but you
know we don't do that with pensions no
we don't you and so so this is a
decision the state has made historically
there have been debates back and forth
on it about whether you fund a benefit a
pension plan or not we report regularly
on on the OPB obligation as that's
called um some of you who go back a few
years we'll remember that um
representative Kirk in particular who
was a who was a longtime chairman of
house finance and and and had very
strong opinions um believe very strongly
in not reserving for retire health and
and I think at the end of the
day if you want to go there at some
point we can outline the arguments for
reserving and against um but it the uh
uh fiscal in particular was generally
hostile to any notion of of
saving and and and allowing this to be
paid as you go in part cuz um the theory
is that that you can
change oh but if you want to reserve we
can work out a plan for you for that so
you're
saying we're not obligated to pay this
money we are right it's a it's a you
could change the nature of the
some part of the population who was not
vested from needing 10 years to needing
20 years I see um you can make changes
like that and and and there are
debates I would want the union to give
you their perspective on on whe on what
you can change and what you can't change
to before saying anything definitive I
suppose if we if we did it via savings
then we would be taking money
essentially from anybody
everybody and only giving it to those
who last 20
years is that right I mean it's it's
that's the problem yes I mean it's one
of the equity issues with funding right
with funding that way with with
prefunding the debt is who are you
taking money from and are they going to
get that benefit or not we have an
obligation under the law I think
everyone knows this that that all the
money
collected for the purpose of the healthc
care benefit both retired benefit and
the and the active benefit um uh through
a mechanism called fund 60 must be used
for that and we may not take money under
the um and pretend it's for health care
and then not use it for healthare I mean
not that we want to we don't want to but
we're not legally allowed to so that
comes up sometimes sure okay so this is
a but this is a giant part of the
general fund here right because half of
our general fund ballpark our isn't it
like 50 million a year no
it's 35
I want yeah and and that's probably page
98 or something like that let me give
you the exact amount 30 and 33 actually
yeah if you look on page 30 okay P page
seven of the short hand out okay um has
that information it's also on page 100
of yeah so it's like half the general
funds half of our 50% of our budget yeah
ium okay let's go on to this okay so
positions you want to talk about
positions these are the positions we
have so slide three um slide three is an
overview and then slides four and five
are line items or people items um we
divided so you understand uh how it
works into plant and property and we we
talked last time a little bit about how
plant and property is is people and
programs are sort of mixed in in that um
risk which has no General funds um uh
that governs any of their positions and
then operations which is the rest of our
department that's you know procurement
and it's everything and where the
reductions are so we go from
3 uh 330 and we go down 29 so far and so
that's most of our
positions and uh most of our currently
vacant positions before I tell you what
vacant positions are I want to say
something about what vacant positions
aren't this is a snapshot in time and I
said to someone the fact that Gail left
last week and her position is suddenly
vacant doesn't mean we weren't using it
if I break my leg and I'm limping I
don't want you to amputate my leg
because I'm not planning on using it and
still ask me to run a marathon and so so
just cuz someone leaves and the position
is vacant next week or last week doesn't
mean we weren't didn't have plans for it
now internally we've had an internal
hiring freeze since about um July um cuz
we can do math and um and kind of knew
where this was going and I I would
rather lose a vacant position than a
person it's just less awkward if you
know what I'm saying um and Humane but
you know we're down and everybody's
hurting and and we're doing a lot so so
we feel like I think at some point we
refer to ourselves as an already fragile
and underst staff department and
somebody said do you really want to put
the word fragile in your
presentation and uh yeah cuz that's
literally who we are so we do I'm very
proud of the work we do and we do a lot
of work and uh I honestly believe if you
eliminated our agency government would
shut down and be illegal um but anyway
so that's where we are so we're down 29
and there 25 left on the on pages four
and
five those are
they the first page is
um unfunded fulltime by source and so
that's what we quote unquote
lost um with an explanation of General
funds Etc and then the second page is
what's still not filled but uh funded in
the draft before
you okay I'm happy to answer any
questions about that but I don't know
exactly where you would like me to go on
that so I will
pause there's a there's another page six
if you get through four and
five which is talks about our part-time
positions so
let's let's talk about just so I make
sure I understand the page three um is
there
275 people
working yeah right now yep is that right
okay and didn't check your mouth think
it's 276 276 yeah so there's 276 people
here and
working yes and um and these these uh 54
people or 54 positions nobody's working
on them right now right right okay but
but if there was no hiring freeze you
could add
25 and and the budget went through as is
yes right exactly right but you could
not add the other 29 if the budget goes
through as is yes yeah okay um one
caveat to what I said as a foot at the
bottom there's a there's a small unit
called the office of Cost Containment
which is being eliminated so there are
those are four positions that are
currently filled with people working in
them it's being eliminated Cost
Containment people we collect people got
provided uh a free lawyer so to speak
and but we collect from some of them
over an enormous amount of time and over
time the amount we collect has gone
steadily down
and so we're we're about to spend more
collecting than we collect and that
seems like a good so I wanted to ask you
about this because we have a house bill
House Bill 611 which does exactly this
right and I I guess it must be already
in house bill to right no to get rid so
we're in we we're just frankly
anticipating that house bill 611 611 is
going to Cassie and I went over
testified for it well not for it we
don't testify for against any without
permission of chief executive we
provided information and suggested a
couple of changes just to make it happen
faster okay my point is the the fiscal
note on House Bill 611 was intriguing
because it said due to previous
legislative changes the amount collected
has been
declining right well so that implies
that we could undo previous legislative
changes and the amount collected would
increase yes right do you know what
those changes are I can I can summarize
them um in I believe it's 2019 I think
was Senator um belus who pushed this or
sponsored it
um so we collect we collected from
everyone in the past and they changed it
to only people
convicted so if you if you got off or
you pled or um then you don't have to
pay and and I think the sponsor's
presumption was and I we don't have an
opinion about do that or don't do that
um we merely pointed out the reduction
was um well if you were found not guilty
why are we charging you and and that's
what that's what they tend to say I
believe the sponsor of the current bill
is a law professor at you at yeah
Franklin and that 2019 change um
required the court to make an order of
the defendant's ability to pay and so if
you think about most defendants and what
their ability to pay is that also
seriously ctail to
collections but somehow in the past well
eventually their situation can change
and you know right I think I think the
the presumption had
been you don't you can't afford now this
week but um when you are working you
could pay a little gotcha all right well
this is something we're going to
struggle with but let's go on Mr I had
to look this up I didn't know what HB
611 was so the title is abolishing
recruitment procedures regarding
appointed Council for Indigent criminal
defendants just so I don't know what if
the other members knew what it was yeah
that's the office of Coss containment
yeah well I didn't well I didn't know
that it's it's people who get um um a
courta appointed attorney right and that
attorney costs something and it's really
um if they have the ability to pay they
should return that money but that's the
idea anyway okay I I don't just so so
you're aware before the change the
approximate amount we collected ballpark
was about 2 million and well this year
we will probably collect about 300,000 I
don't and the office is the 300,000 dis
cost right yeah um so it's on the edge
right but it's yeah but it used to be a
significant increase yeah so I mean
eight years ago I looked at this in a in
a different context when I
was I was the governor's budget director
and we looked at it and I said so what
do you spend how much you raise and and
leaving aside I didn't know whether it's
a good idea or bad idea someone's like
well we spend 500 Grand then and we
raised 2.4 million and I'm like oh okay
and then we didn't pursue it but you
know when the lines cross it's not just
bad in Ghostbusters yeah I mean I this
is
well let's sa that we we have limited
time here so okay so that's where we are
in positions good and then just as as a
followup is as Charlie mentioned the the
29 that were unfunded and that was in
our agency and our governor phase it
didn't change between the two phases all
that detail is on page four and then
once again page five would be all the
currently vacant but funded positions
and it's also that's about 25 and then
you'll notice some are a a combination
of Z to 100% generally funded right some
as early as a week ago ended up on the
list but those positions are not
eliminated no neither one of them are
they're unfunded they're just un fund
okay yes our counts so that's a really
good point is so when you look at the
the 330 yes it doesn't change because
there're 301 yes right the dollar
dollars are gone although the position
counts don't change understand I think
the point they're trying to make is just
because they're vacant it doesn't mean
that they're not needed yes so they want
to keep the funding for so they can fill
them I understand all right thank you go
ahead
okay um if there aren't other questions
about
that and you can see the part-timers on
page
six um we have a lot of part-time people
in plant and property in particular a
lot of the building cleaners um in fact
that you might see at the State House
even um are part-time positions we've
actually had an enormous um
success with um there's a there's a
significant nepales community in conquer
and
um uh We've we've recruited really good
people from there and we're
nice which allows you to recruit their
friends too so if you're a good employer
that people talk so so we decided that's
not just a good human strategy it's also
a good recruitment strategy um we
summarized spending 23 vacant out of 66
um there's a churn it's a part-time job
cleaning and if I'm honest my guess is
very few people think of that as their
their goal and they move on during
during uh during the covid years um or
whatever you want to call that um state
of emergency we had a lot of trouble
recruiting
um a Dunkin Donuts was paying more and
you don't necessarily have to do some of
the things that you have to do for us
and and there's
some a little better vital to the you
know I said well they say cleanliness is
closest thing to Godliness right so it
doesn't make the position less vital and
important no we sort of it's a thing we
can't not clean I mean we don't take
people's trash out for them but you
can't not clean the bathroom and mop the
floor I think that I think there are
rules about occupying buildings okay if
you look at the if you look at our our
our
f um so there are line items and then
there are expense categories seven is
just a summary but on lines eight pages
eight and nine by both Total funds and
general funds we wanted to summarize for
you the major categories of spending and
these These are largely class lines in
the budget and the change just so you
can see in the
aggregate um where things are in case
you wanted uh in the past sometimes the
house has wanted summaries of that sort
to look at and say all right what's
going on here what changed on this um
you know what went up
here and the comparison is is
particularly 26 to 25 adjusted
authorized um because that doesn't
include Granite place or anything like
that um but if you any any questions on
any of those lines I'm happy to to talk
about let's talk about the big ones
software in for this State we manage um
as I think you know we manage the
state's Erp the state's enterprise
resource planning planning platform the
the computer that does the business
everything the business of state
government HR payroll Finance
purchasing everything yeah um pay bills
pay people and and do everything else um
we're upgrading it's uh the the major
upgrade when we when we purchased it I
think they were called Lawson at the
time people make remember was in
2008 yeah um drove Sher away from state
government um but she came back um and
uh this is this is the the major upgrade
we're moving to the cloud the new
product is called Cloud Suite
technically you can't not move to the
cloud you can't not upgrade your system
or you rely on two 85y old men who both
want to move to Florida I think there's
some system in state government where
that's literally the case um and um and
we're upgrading it's a lot of work it's
an enormous amount of stress on on
actually basically my whole department
um except plant and property
who aren't doing implementation they
have a different stress but um and the
annual licensing fee for that um
software is essentially going to go from
1 million to 2 million okay and I I want
to tell you that I think computers are
wonderful and very efficient and
expensive us all get out and I feel like
like there's a whole bunch of people
meeting in Bill Gates's house figuring
out how to get money out of the rest of
us so what what the commissioner of doit
told us was basically that when you're
doing stuff by hand and you computerize
it then you've get a big savings right
but once you're already computerized and
you go to the next computer there's no
saving and the vendor knows you're over
a barrel and so costs are going faster
than inflation so I it's a great example
like with this we looked at doing a
complete reprocurement where we went out
to bid and we talked to workday and
Oracle and everybody else who bids in
that market or upgrading with our
current vendor who's one of the the big
five but um and it's really really
really expensive to upgrade with our
current vendor vendor and a lot less
money than if we went out to Bid And so
it's and and you know so so that is a
big thing okay one thing I I'll notice
is that yesterday when commissioner
Steph from Dr talked about their change
in their Rim software you'll notice that
their big increase happened in class 27
because they're operating their Rim
system that operation doit support so it
moved from their capital budget into
class 27 this is not in class 27 we pay
in4 directly have to be class 38 but
it's our I'm sorry our software line um
that we pay because we the sap system so
it's in a different spot than than rims
but the same concept that it's that
operation of the cloud product okay all
right the contract for services p and
p oh uh yeah plant and property uh uh
contracted services so the way we do
maintenance in
um I I want you to look at the line
above it if you would together with this
um because we do some things out of
class 103 which would be services so
buildings and grounds building and
grounds so this is P&P plant and
property so these are the the contracts
elevator contracts fire alarm contracts
carpentry contracts all of the contracts
that you'll see in the division lines at
at plant and property
our during the governor's phase agency
phase and Governor's phase our Direction
was to hit a 4% number for total funds
and general funds in that division in
the Aggregate and to figure out the and
and to make sure that what we're billing
agencies in the aggregate does not go up
by more than or goes down by 4% as well
and so what we did is is we made changes
across the division and in some cases we
took if when there's room we then put it
in this line and so what happens in in
those lines is is some portion of of the
line is existing contracts and it might
be snow plowing and it might be fire
extinguishers it might be like monthly
Main contracts and it might be other
work contracts and then what's left we
use to fix stuff for deferred
maintenance so so so Donnie parin for
for Central facilities for example will
have a list of the things he wants to
fix and if there's money we fix them and
if there's not we don't so it's deferred
maintenance and yes sorry as Charlie
mentioned the overall for that entire
division um did go down 4% so while this
specific line um increased overall for
the division still went down um 4% and
if you notice on the next slide where
this is total funds uh the general funds
are significantly smaller they're about
less than 10% of the pl property budget
ends up being General funds um because
we uh of the reallocation that goes out
to all the agencies in terms of the
billing now it doesn't mean those
agencies are paying General funds yes
and that's why we didn't keep we have to
look out for the other
division so our directive when we were
working to our agency of Governor St is
our overall our department for General
funds went down 4% we' supplied or
applied that same logic to our planting
property so even though it doesn't look
like General funds we still decrease
that overall budget by that same per we
we could probably show you at some point
too where
um what what the governor's office had
wanted from
us although to be honest it was my
suggestion that they should want it was
um to for us to do a spreadsheet and say
what are your billing agents genes CU I
can't come to you and go we don't have
any general funds here because it's
because people pay them and it's like
you know do is the biggest thing like
that right and you know do has I pay do
with mostly General funds and same thing
with plan property the second biggest
thing in state government like that and
so he said do me a do me a list to go up
or down and you must go down by 4% so we
did and so we put we put money there and
it's it is extra money to do deferred
maintenance is how we do deferred
maintenance is we
use the money that's not been taken by
the contract increases for deferred
maintenance
um having said that I'm going to be
honest with you it it means there's some
flexibility there but if you take it
something won't get
fixed yeah um although the state has a
long history of not fixing anything
thank you I I've been trying to figure
out where it was appropriate to ask this
question so I'm going to ask it now
we're obviously talking a lot to the
judicial branch um and I'm trying to
understand the
interrelationship between
Das and the judicial branch and I found
on your little H your hand out here I
found page 15 I don't know if that's the
territory yep but it's at the very
bottom so you just well because they're
talking about the situation with perhaps
closing cour houses and and if you could
help us with that I'd appreciate it so
um 15 and and the spreadsheet is on 16
um there was a time when the courts took
care of their own buildings I want to
say the 90s but don't hold me to that
and it went back and forth a little bit
and then at some point they decided I
think we're
judges we're not as good at taking care
of buildings so we take that we have a a
bureau called The Bureau of Court
facilities that spends more than $10
million and we take care of all the cour
houses across State and we when we
arrange all the leases for the cour
houses across the state and we do work
in all the cour houses across the state
so when I tell you we we do 92 or 95
buildings Statewide it includes all the
cour houses as well and that's a big
chunk so that part of our budget is done
in concert with them so for example
Sarah linbury is the administrator there
who works for K raki and um and I said
to Sarah and Karen um so here's your
target your target is 4%
um but that's not Sarah's Target it's
whatever the Chief Justice says and if
if they because the branch would get its
own Target and and I know that's a
little weird in the in a relationship
but um if they decide we want to cut 20%
out of
Maintenance and 4% out of everything
else they can and so we we maintain
buildings in the in the manner in which
they're willing to fund so the numbers
that we see here are more coming from
them well well they set sort of what
they want to do they I mean what happens
is is we have actually a wonderful
working relationship with them where
where they trust Sarah implicitly and
say well what is this cost and what does
that cost there are actually quarterly
meetings at the I served on that yeah
the court accreditation why I know Sarah
yeah and so and and you know that she's
very knows what she's doing and uh so
we'll work with them and they'll say
well what about this well what happens
if I do this so this is a back and forth
and it's typically Sarah meeting with
Diane Martin the budget that's here
represents where it left really the
agency
phase um these numbers support where the
judicial branch was at the end of their
agency phase and the reason I say that
is the um governor in House Bill 2 made
some reductions to the judicial branch
we didn't make um tweaks to our budget
because the digital Branch at the time
had it made specific decisions and the
legislature hasn't chimed in in terms of
do all the C courts operate do half of
them operate you know for example if we
decrease courts that we lease the rent
line would come down if we um if they
Clos courts that we own then we'd have
decreases in our maintenance staff to
support those buildings if we're not
going to be in them electricity would
change depending on the volume of the
the number of cours so this is a fluid
so after you finish with the branch and
I don't know that you have
um this accounting unit will change
based on what you do but the the money
for this accounting unit is in their
budget as a as a class 28 transfer to us
so so when that changes we will adjust
all of these numbers to fit in
particular they told us if we wanted
Cuts they would cut um the courthouse in
hookit and gtown are those rented or
leased
they're leased okay and are these but
are we in long-term leases or can we
stop as of July 1 generally we can the
state generally has language and leases
that allow us to um get out when there
are no funds that that that's a caveat
in those leases okay good well I think
though that that's included in their 4%
reduction anyway they were choosing
between candy and Claremont and they
replace Claremont with so it's not like
if we have them do that we're going to
get more cuts understanding is the
agency phase included right elimination
of cour houses yes so the other question
is just what what is the the Personnel
lines then within Court facilities what
are those those aren't the judges so who
are no they're M what are they it's the
maintenance staff okay it's it's
building
cleaners um construction everybody okay
all right we I let me back up so plant
and property um is has two parallel
components AR arguably and and one is
what we call Central facilities which
used to be two or three bureaus and and
three years ago the then Governor made
us combine them
um but he he let us at the time keep
Court facilities a separate Bureau but
they all have the same stuff because
they they all clean buildings so they
have building cleaners they all have
maintenance tchs because they all
maintain buildings and they all I mean
on and on and on they don't have people
they don't overlap in that for the most
part I mean if somebody needs help that
that's a different thing but for the
most part people are assigned to a set
of
buildings right so this line just Mr
chair one more thing so I just want to
be clear this line that we're looking in
your budget is the cost of the Court
facilities or and their maintenance all
of that's what we're looking at it
exactly right but it's all transferred
from the 100 plus million I get it but
it's also living here yeah okay um and
when you make changes we'll change it so
back to page eight of the presentation
yes so then there's um the federal
government buying
lunch so what is that um there's a
program called Surplus foods and it's
run out of the warehouse on St Street it
was at one time years ago called the New
Hampshire Distributing agency but the
federal government distributes food to
lots and lots of to all states who then
distribute food to in our case mostly
schools a little bit of food banks but
mostly schools and there's an
arrangement with the schools it is
federally funded um with a $155,000
state match which is a decent return on
a million dollar program um and it's uh
uh it's going up because of the the
federal the
school districts pay a per case charge
for the food that they get and that per
case charge has changed and it it goes
up and down when the
federal um um allotment to the state
goes up and down and so it recently went
up which is why you which is why you see
that interesting but it's all federal
funds gotta okay page
nine oh this is General same thing same
thing in general funds okay and you'll
notice there's not really any different
categories that pop out we haven't
already talked about so there's um but
well there's rents I guess yeah and I
can talk so the rents on this page are
fairly fairly small I will make one
comment that on page eight the rent line
um went down so if you go back to page
eight I did want to point this out so
rents other than leas is 4.5 73 almost
4.6 million went down to 38 some of that
decrease now obviously some rents go up
some rents go down but we had by
purchasing Granite place that used to be
a lease for us and then we have since
purchased it so the budget for 2425
reflected um still leasing that so some
of these costs have been reflected in 26
27 with uh that one specific building
changing and so retiree Health this
overall 6% increase over the bium I mean
this just normal increase in health
costs right I mean yeah so yeah we
avoided the normal increase in health
cost for a while with with very
aggressive procurement strategies but um
we used to always say the fisal to
aren't any more rabbits in the Hat and
so um I I will say this it's important
it's important to know that that we're
probably not going to be good at
predicting well where 2027 is a
significant portion of healthcare costs
are dictated by federal policy and
federal reimbursements and I I don't
think anyone
has a really strong sense
today on what exactly is going on in
Washington
DC okay page 10 this oh yes sorry
represent LE thanks Mr chairman so it's
just curious of the number of retirees
on the St retiree Health
Plan I can have I can provide that for
you um we have
10,906 Medicare retirees and we we also
have retirees who aren't eligible for
for Medicare early retirees
1580 and then when further question some
time ago we talked about a small
contribution that they would pay in uh
what are they paying in now as because I
know the state doesn't pay 100% of it
but right non-medicare retirees pay 20%
of the monthly premium it's um let me
see if I have the figure here uh they
are paying
one no the pre
167 yeah that sounds right right um and
per month and I feel like that's not
right so let me let me just verify that
for you
um when we had the budget trouble with
retire Health back in fiscal 16 and 17
and when Charlie was working for the
governor as the budget officer that was
the first time we implemented a pre
premium contribution for our Medicare
retirees and they pay 10% of the premium
and you may remember I mentioned when we
were last here in late January that we
worked with rep obber at the time and we
grandfathered um the oldest retirees who
had the lowest pensions and so um what
what obviously happens is um new people
come into the plan and then people also
um pass away so we are down to
4759 retirees who are Medicare retirees
who are still
grandfathered okay um one other thing a
smaller number it is a smaller the one
thing I want to mention to you so that
you know this too is um over over I
think since 2009 the state has been
trying to um limit who gets through the
door to be eligible for retire health
and that's why you hear their age limits
and and years of service limits right um
one of the things the state did back in
the around the 2010 time frame was we
used to pay for the Medicare Part B
premium for the Medicare retirees we
don't pay that and they now pay that
that's what the 167 is is the Medicare
Part thanks thanks Mr chairman
so so are you saying that 6,000 or so
paid 10% yes yes okay and and uh 40
4,800 pay nothing correct right okay and
then quite old and 1600 pay
20% is that kind of yeah yes okay
exactly right the 1600 who pay
20% um it's also a much more more
expensive benefit the the 10% of the of
the Medicare benefit is quite small oh
less than $80
H it's not $80 it's not half of the
167 no it's 10% of 167 so it's 16 right
the Medicare premium the non-medicare
premium is
$1,478 and and you might say why is it
so high compared to the Medicare premium
right it's because not Medicare eligible
there are no federal funds coming in to
pay for part of their healthare yeah I
mean that's what I pay right so yes yes
exactly so okay
and so you're saying the 6,000 people
are paying like $20 or something yes I
see okay go we get them on one pager on
who pays um that was a big change for
those retirees um back in
2017 there was it it took a lot to get
there okay do
you is it easy to collect I mean is it
sort of automatic or do they have
everybody writing a check or is it uh
well writing a check is not easy okay
because people don't and then when you
do you have to H process them right it
used to be easier to collect because of
the retirement um New Hampshire
retirement system um and it's a
complicated story and I if you want I
think we talk about it on the side but
essentially they stopped collecting from
certain retirees and we had to hire a
billing service to help us collect so um
it's it's not easy to collect
okay so we need to talk to them about
that
is the retirement
system we should have a longer
conversation about that okay all right
we'll make a note to that there are two
sides to every
story our side tends to be angrier so
Melissa Melissa you want to make a note
about this yeah to to remind me to do
that y we can do that okay okay um good
so let's talk about the next page page
10 so one of the things you one of the
things you had said you wanted to talk
about is um programs and obviously we do
very few programmatic things but there's
a rumor that you have an interest in
Paid Family Leave I stole your sheet oh
that's mine yeah okay so Cassie is going
to talk about Paid Family Leave because
it took 10 years off her
life it it really did and um my life may
expire
um so I talked about this when we were
last here um paid family medical leave
was passed in House Bill 2 of 2021 um we
implemented it over a period of a year
and a half and we first offered retire
um paid family medical leave for sale in
December of 23 the structure of the
program I think is a good place to start
because it probably will lay out your
questions for you right so under the law
that was passed there's a purpose
section in that law that says that we we
we the state of New Hampshire desire to
create a a advantageous market for paid
family medical leave and in order to
accomplish that we're going to provide a
um Paid Family Leave benefit to all
state employees that will which is
approximately 8900 people okay and that
creates um the the incentive for a
vendor a carrier to come into our state
and then administer the paid family
medical leave on a voluntary basis so
what that means is that um Employers in
the state of New Hampshire can decide if
they want to purchase paid family
medical leave for their um employees
they decide um whether they want base
coverage or they want to buy up coverage
and and you know my slides cover what
the base coverage is and um they also
can decide whether their their employees
contribute to the
cost
um there because the program is
voluntary for employers I I if I'm an
employer I don't have to buy it and I
don't have to pay for the whole thing
there are going going to be some
employees in the state of New Hampshire
who will not have access to paid family
medical leave so the other unique thing
about our law is it set up something
called an individual plan so that if an
employee worked for an employer who did
not pro purchase paid family medical
leave or through its own benefit
structure have comparable benefits
available an individual can go to this
individual group through MetLife our
contractor and purchase paid family
medical leave on their own um there is
an annual open enrollment for that um
individual plan and this is our third o
Open Enrollment and we now have 1,800
people who have applied to for coverage
uh under the as individuals yes um so
what do we pay for what does the state
pay for we pay for the state employee
benefit
that is uh I on the slide on page 10 I
you see the total funds for fiscal 24
was 1.4 52 million where do you find
that you find that it's spread out in
every Department's budget in the class
60 associated with employees it's just a
minor piece and the rate is very
reasonable Sher can you save it for me
it's
207% of cover will
be like 1 of 1% the second second
207%
027 and what what fraction of these 8900
state employees make
claims
um well it's relatively new so um minor
I did send you folks the information
with the claims data I I don't have it
at my fingertips I'm sorry but but um I
I'll say it was about a 100 people who
have made claims in the last year or so
okay can I yes I just want to add
something so the point 207 works out the
fiscal 24 was about 1.4
million and and just as a note it's
about 550 Grand in general funds
Statewide because if if you if you think
about our our employee benefits are you
want a ballpark things about 40% General
funds 40% non or 60% non-general funds
so so so that the state the the the cost
of the coverage for the state employees
is is the contractual monetary basis for
our contract with metti okay um and then
they provide the voluntary program to
employers and to
individuals when does that contract end
that contract ends I put it someplace
here in 2027 I think 12327
um and we we have other contracts
so so 12 3127 and it has an option to
extend for two additional years so we
can't change that in this B budget is
that what you're saying no I'm not
saying that um I I think it's important
that you know that that's what the
contract is okay um and what and how we
fund that contract is through the state
employee premium so and I I'm operating
on assumptions I spoke to Rich labors
Deputy Commissioner over at nhes who was
here last week um
so if the desire is to look at
eliminating paid family medical leave
um this accounting unit information that
you have supports uh Consulting contract
supports a marketing contract and
supports a very minor contract with a
company called silvertech from
Manchester that um has produced uh we
we've provided all the content but our
beautiful website that I told you about
um and um so if if you desire to to
eliminate the expense for paid family
medical leave um if you cut the state
employee benefit I know that you folks
asked Rich what do you think will happen
and he said talk to the AG's office well
I'll give you my personal opinion and
that's all it is and for what it's worth
it will be the death now for Paid Family
Medical Le because it is through the
state employee benefit that the that
metti makes a profit of course okay so
um I think if that profit is eliminated
at best you see them remain and be
passive
um but at worst they say okay then we're
we're out of this contract right
um the
law
required Das and nhes to provide
marketing and Outreach for paid family
medical leave um there is a bill to
repeal paid family medical leave it is
House Bill
517 um when I get back to my office
today for what it's worth I will be
sending an amendment to Chairman hunt as
he requested to um eliminate the
marketing responsibilities for dis and
nhes um and but but
otherwise um not repeal Paid Family
Medical so there are different ways you
can look at if you're interested in
doing something with this program what
do you do I think if you eliminate the
state employee benefit my personal
opinion is the whole thing will die if
you might decide to to gut the Das
operational budget for it so but you
said that the contract goes through 2027
correct so met life's contract yeah
right so but I could end it July 1st
2026 or not um I think if you decided to
eliminate the state employee benefit I
would go back to Matti and say this is
what it's looking like okay and I and I
believe they would say to us well that's
the whole basis for the contract where
we want to terminate the contract and I
don't think the state would have much of
a legal leg to stand on to say you can't
do that since it's what we pay them well
that's what we would want them to do no
that if that's what you direct yeah yeah
I understand okay I I guess I anyways
represent one now the other the other
point just to so the the state spend as
opposed to the me life spend um it's the
1.4 million that's scattered throughout
the budget which is 550 in general funds
and then we can we can talk in a minute
but the other expenses are all in this
accounting unit right we eliminated the
position so that's not there and and the
small silvertech contract and then two
other contracts which we we could save
little bits here and there yeah yeah now
let me ask you there's one number we
don't have you have in this program
there's 8,900 state employees there's
1,800 uh private employees who get
individuals so what about companies that
buy it for their whole staff um so I
have some updated numbers let me find
them I'm sorry little bit and are they
also paying 0.2% of payroll for those
people is everybody paying so so let me
pause because I didn't go into that
detail pardon me first of all start on
the individual side because it's easy to
understand the law caps the individual
pool premium at $5 a week the goal is
stated in the law is to have reasonable
rates okay so if you're Met Life you're
under that pressure anyway every person
in the individual pool is individually
rated so they're going to look at my age
um they're going to look at um am I in
childbearing age you know like they're
going to rate me um the same occurs for
an employer when an employer says to
metti I would like a quote they provide
a census of their employees where
they're going to look at male female
demographics Etc and they're also going
to look at what other benefits do you
provide to your employees because
they're what they're trying to answer is
if an employee has a a need to access a
benefit how soon are they going to
access mine underp Paid Family Leave
right so every employer is individually
rated too
okay so so you asked me what was the
employer enrollment yes so um but but
it's the state is paying roughly this $5
a week also a little less it looks like
yes less $4 a week or something depends
on how much you
make okay but but on average for these
8,900 people yeah okay go ahead so tell
me the before I get to represent wer
Tell me number um we have now
308 employers who have purchased
coverage for their
workers um now remember I mentioned a
one employer might pay for it 100% right
but if I say to my employees you pay you
pay 50% you pay 20% Then I'm going to
decide as an employee do I want to py
this right so so um those those
employers today um let's see uh we have
20 so there there's how many people have
access to the coverage
23,600 people actually covered by
employers is
13,37 great all right repres
representative
wer why are we hearing this figure of$
million that this would save the state
if it was cancelled it only seems like
it would save a million and a
half um I don't know why you're hearing
10 million representative wer but it is
the million and a half for the state
employee benefit plus the operational
expenses that are on this slide I list
my slide but if you got rid of the
marketing that saves a have 400 million
if
you a thousand but if you so if you got
let's just say for the sake of argument
that you know I'm not recommending this
that you got rid of the entire program
you just said U this accounting unit
gone and and we're eliminating the state
employee benefit you'd save about 550
General funds on the benefit and you
could theoretically reduce uh we have
700 Grand in for the accounting unit so
you would save in terms of General funds
about ballpark 1.2 million I it's
possible that somebody per year per year
somebody got the wrong end of the stick
and told you 10 million and maybe they
missed a decimal point and I also
remember who told you that so I can't
say I don't know I just saw it somewhere
but also that I saw somewhere you had to
be paying in for 17 months before you
could exercise this okay um what you're
referencing is applies to the individual
plan and it's actually in the law it
there is a seven Monon waiting period
before you can file a claim that will be
reviewed and accepted and um the waiting
period I I remember working with the
Department of Insurance at the time and
the commissioner described it as a
deductible it's a one-time 7mon waiting
period so if I purchase January 1 I have
to wait seven months to have a claim but
if I stay in next year and the and the
and the following years I never have
another waiting period there is
something called an elimination period
which is common in Insurance um uh you
know coverage and and that is a one we
um
waiting period and that the goal of that
is is there a real claim here is it not
just I have to go to a doctor's
appointment you know another thing I
read is that the the private uh
purchases are mostly women in the uh
childbearing age um that that that is um
the bulk of the claims experience is for
bonding with children um and
um I think that's important for you to
understand um what what would be the
consequence if if it were unfunded and
the and the program basically ends now
for the 100 people roughly of state
employees who receive
benefits do you know how much in total
benefits they
got um they get what anyone gets which
is the base coverage 60% of their base
wages up to the social security cap for
up to six weeks yeah but I want this in
terms of dollarss per year total I can
get you that information okay like how
much did meti pay how much did meti pay
out in benefits to those to those hund I
mean presumably it's less than the 1.42
million it most certainly
is yeah but is it is it 80% of it is it
10% of it it's going to be a low
percentage oh I see okay okay great it's
not the big savings that somebody has
told no it is not it's not a huge amount
of savings and um the re there there's
some there's one more thing I'd like you
to know so when I talk to community
groups because it's our statutory
obligation about paid family medical
leave one of the things we talk about is
that paid family medical leave is being
debated across the country in every
single state and at the federal level as
well and there there is a federal
bipartisan working group that has
recently come out with recommendations
and the New Hampshire model is one of
those recommendations the beauty of the
New Hampshire model is that it's really
very lean you're you're transferring the
the administration of the program to the
insurance carrier uh the first time I
sat in on a a bipartisan working group
call uh I was there there were States
like Colorado and Washington present and
they conduct the administration of their
plan so um rich labers and I and our two
two other staff people that was the New
Hampshire working group right uh would
listen to Colorado talk about how they
hired a 100 people right so if you're
going to do this and you think it's
important I think this is the way to do
it you know it's very it's very very
lean and I will say with a lot of Pride
we did a good job to help educate the
public okay but let's oose that the
let's just talk about the state
employees let's suppose that of those
8,900 state employees the 100 who get
the benefit only get $500,000 worth of
benefit or something like
that can we get rid of MetLife and all
the external people Al together and give
those 100 employees who qualify the
$500,000 of
benefit do you see what I mean and and
and only pay that well directly I mean
if you're interested in the program
continue and I don't want to argue with
you I'm I'm just trying to explain so if
let me know um if you're interested in
the program continuing to be available
to the public right um then I believe
that the state employee premium that we
pay metti is the key to Met Life
continuing to honor our contract
okay
um it's
Insurance any insurance you're paying
something for every person who's I call
it a member right and then only member
only certain numbers of members make a
claim right so so I don't personally
feel it's about the state employees who
have accessed the coverage and been paid
I think it's about the real issue is the
structure of the law that says you're
going to provide this benefit to State
Employees to create a market to
incentivize a carrier to come into New
Hampshire and operate this voluntary
plan right but
I that's not my question but no I'll
just note this you yes you could if we
if we're interested in making sure 8,900
state employees have access to this
particular benefit you could cut a check
for access to that benefit and if if
that's the goal the the program with a
little bit of administrative overhead
presumably but not probably because we'd
have to um but it it's worth noting that
if that's the goal yeah absolutely easy
peasy okay um the program wasn't set up
to do that I understand program program
was set up as an alternative to a state
paid leave program to a to a a state
funded paid leave program and it was to
create a private market and the employee
benefit is not there for the state
employees it's there to create a market
so somebody would bid right but it's
only 15 right now thousand people that
are getting no it's not you don't know
we don't want to be in that business
right not s insurance I'm not
disagreeing I mean you're absolutely
right and you could absolutely do that
all right now we're way beyond our time
and so we're going to have to ask you
back at some other point we would love
to come back maybe for only a half an
hour or something like that but we'll
work it out with Melissa so okay can I
just ask some like super easy how much
money do you save if you get rid of the
marketing requirement the way marketing
is is it just how much money we a lot of
money marketing is in class 102 there's
a little bit of it's the very last line
on my slide 10 marketing is to 250 250
250 and the consultant is
450 spring which is a benefit all right
gotcha so it is the bulk of this yeah it
is actually so the Outreach is a lot of
it yeah okay thanks all right thank you
thanks for having us yeah I mean you're
a 50 page agency so it's like
complicated if you want to go line by
line I'm ready for that I know you would
be we haven't done hb2 yeah so we'll
we'll definitely try to have you back
for hb2 our HB stuff is very
admin okay
well but we have to talk
about I
understand coming back at
e
e e
yeah so actually um I think we're going
to start on page 288
um so we'll invite Mr attorney
general
welcome thank you Mr Mr chairman members
of the committee uh John formela
attorney general and with me is Kathy
Carr our director of
administration did you want us to go
through our presentation or are you just
going to jump right in and ask us about
various lines and things yeah let's
let's go to any page that has numbers on
it maybe like
um so let me just let me give you a
little preview of where we're at um
so
um
basically the governor was really
optimistic as far as revenues go from
our point of view and so we're going to
have to cut things and um one one me
measure we're
using in of um what's sort of the right
size of things or at least part of the
input to our process is um what was in
the fiscal year 2019 budget compared to
today so
um because 2019 was was sort of
preco and it's it's a good six years and
so on and since then
um there's been like 25% inflation plus
4% population growth so you could say
well kind of a medium sort of number for
an increase over 2019 would be 30% maybe
something like that well um in terms of
General
funds um let's see where you guys are
you
guys
are I'm not seeing oh there it is yeah
so
so you guys have are really have an
increase a serious increase I mean the
the um just from 2019 to
2025 um
104% so of worth of General funds and in
all funds only 37% so so the amount of
General funds your department is
consuming it is in first blush very very
high and so um we may have to uh make
more severe Cuts here than than in other
places so um what I'm interested in is
these kind of numbers like you have here
on page three with you know how many
cases you're dealing with and all that
sort of thing how many calls how many um
and and whatever you can say
about how do you measure productivity
because all your all of your EXP
expenses our attorneys and staff and
people right and and so how do you
measure um
productivity and how do you think
of you know so much per case so much per
you know so many cases per person or
something like that or is it or is it so
many court cases you know I mean you
probably have a difference
between criminal cases and non-criminal
cases and you know whether something
gets settled or goes to court and things
like that but but I just
wondering how do we see whether how do
you think of the different departments
and whether they're performing well not
performing
well yeah that's
a uh good question so let me so there
there's a few different ways we we
measure performance of the Department of
Justice right so
the the first and foremost I would say
is that every agent and the Department
of Justice is no exception is only as
good as its people so we we look to you
know measure the performance and growth
of our individual employees whether
there's at whether they're attorneys
paralegals legal support staff so every
employee is evaluated on on a regular
basis so that that's I think that's the
first what I would say first is
evaluations that are done for for
each employee we also look at just hours
that people are putting in per week the
legal profession especially is one that
often is you know we we measure you know
hours people are spending on on cases
hours of attorney time in the private
sector hours of attorney time is how you
measure sort of Revenue that you're
bringing in if if you're if you're a law
firm so we we measure that we try to
keep an eye on you know the number of
hours an attorney is spending it's just
it's just working per week uh case
numbers is a I mean we we we provide
these numbers to you in our presentation
just so you have a
snapshot it's a little difficult I think
to measure someone's workload or
productivity by the number of quote
cases they have because every case is
different some cases are very
complicated and take a lot of time some
cases are pretty quick and we also sort
of we have cases so we think of cases as
active litigation matters right either
somebody has sued the state and now we
are litigating that case or we have
opened a
investigation and even further down the
road have filed criminal charges so now
we're Prosecuting a case or we brought
an enforcement action so we have cases
we also measure in matters the
difference between a matter and a case
is anytime just an issue has to be
worked on or addressed or analyzed we'll
often open a separate matter in our
system which we it's called praw so so
there are cases people have a number of
cases they also have a number of open
matters they're working on and a matter
can evolve into a case or or not but it
it still takes work so and then we of
course measure and we
don't we don't necessarily do this uh in
an exact quantitative way but we're
we're looking at how successful are we
in our cases you know are we winning are
we losing um we don't just look at that
because we have some very difficult
cases that we're often on defense on
where we're up against the eightball
right and and so uh so we don't just
measure in whether we're winning or not
we also we trying to look at the quality
of of work people are doing the quality
of their pleadings uh and and get a
sense of how how people are developing
as as writers or or oral Advocates so
that that's sort of how we measure
quality growth growth uh productivity
but at the end of the day at the
Department of Justice we are basically
doing the work that lands in our lap for
for the most part right so if the state
gets sued we're handling the cases if
crimes are committed we're Prosecuting
them a lot of the the types of cases we
do with some exceptions we we will
basically do all of those cases so for
instance we handle all of the murder
cases that happen in the state we handle
all allegations of criminal conduct
against on duty law en or state
officials we are the only agency doing
Medicaid fraud right drug cases are a
little bit different we we do the more
serious drug cases but we also try at
times to to just take some of the load
off of the County attorneys so we're
we're sort of do doing the work that
comes to us and for the most part not
doing the work that that doesn't land in
our lab there's some discretion but but
we're we're a law enforcement agency for
the most part at at the end of the day
so so in general is your impression that
crime is up or down over the last I
don't know decade half decade something
like
that or about the same as it yeah uh so
a couple things on that I I I can say
until last year it seemed the number of
homicides per year were trending up
historically we've had 18 to 19 I guess
I shouldn't say homicides murder cases
that come to the Department of Justice
say 181 19 per year uh I believe in 22
and 23 we were in in the high 20s you
know so the the average number of of
murder murders in the state has been
trending up not in a uh I would say
um too dramatic sense but it you know if
you go from if you think about it from a
percentage standpoint it's pretty pretty
significant but I I I hesitate to think
in percentages when you're starting at
numbers like 18 and 19 because you could
have three or four but this piece of
paper says
well that for one that's bium but it's
also okay I I think homicide
cases both new ones that are opened and
cases we're working on right so if a
murder happens in 2022 you know the
trial is probably going to happen maybe
in late 2023 2024 so so we both we get
new cases all the
time and we've still got the cases we're
working on I see so this is the number
of active cases total over the bium is
that kind of what it is I see as opposed
to the number that was opened and the
number that was
closed correct yeah that might be a
better way to measure it yeah yeah there
are different ways to measure like I
said these numbers we have given you
just to be clear and transparent they're
not meant to say to you you know this is
to give this is to really closely track
the productivity of the Department of
Justice it's to give you a snapshot if I
were going to try to get into the weeds
and track that productivity for you I
think I would have a presentation just
based on that and really hone in on
these numbers so I I don't want to and
i' we've presented numbers like this I
think in just about every budget
presentation for you know going back as
far as I can remember since I've either
been attorney general or Governor's
legal council this is meant to give you
a snapshot so sure there are different
ways to measure the numbers
okay all right let's go to the uh page I
guess it's page five so this says uh
recoveries this looks like the good news
right
yes so um we've sued other people and
received 98 million over the bium is
that it yeah so so recoveries is um it's
meant to Encompass both both sort of new
cases where we've recovered money and
also just on goinging settlements say
yearslong settlements where we have to
do work at the doj that brings in
Revenue so this this number is actually
lower than in some past two-year periods
because this number does include the
tobacco money so when you take the
tobacco money out of 98 million we
actually in 23 and 24 didn't do as well
as we've done in some other twoyear
periods I still include it here because
it's Revenue the office is generating
because the state doesn't just get the
tobacco money by doing nothing we get it
regularly but we have a lot of
obligations we have to continue to meet
and a lot of work we have to do to make
sure we're getting our our tobacco
payment and the doj is doing that so
it's work we're doing that's that's
bringing in it's bringing in revenue and
it is it's a continued recovery the
tobacco settlement is it's a it's an
infinite you know it's sort of like the
time period on that is infinite right
it's just ongoing ongoing in definitely
so it's not a certain fraction of
tobacco sold in New Hampshire or
something like that well it's it it's
it's based it's based on statistics like
that but also based on the type of
enforcement enforcement work we're doing
there's there's a lot that goes into it
so it's formula based but also based on
work we have to continue to do to meet
our obligations under the agreement
because we noticed that um The Liquor
Commission does some tobacco enforcement
they have a section where they go and
you know send a 20-year-old in to buy a
cigarett and you know find people if
they don't if they sell to them and
things like that right so right yeah
what the state gets is it's based on the
Statewide efforts right so it's it's not
just the doj doing say the enforcement
work but the doj is responsible for
tracking everything that's happening so
you look into that kind of stuff making
sure we're meeting our obligations if
we're not correcting what needs to be
corrected so that we don't endanger that
Revenue stream gotcha
okay um oh opioid settlement that's
oxycotton or something is yeah so those
are the various opioid lawsuits we we've
brought over over the past uh six to
seven years and it we just track the
money that is continuing to come in that
we're continuing to recover from those
settlements
okay
um all right yeah it might be better for
these kind of to have a little more
detail of Year bye kind of things for
this you know for like a 5-year period
or something like that can I ask
question yes go ahead
represent so um under doj recoveries you
have Grant funds managed is that a
recovery or what does what is that
category so Grant F we we go out and we
apply for federal grants we bring the
grant money in and much of our grant
money is is subg granted out to others
so either other state agencies or other
uh entities out in the state so it we I
include it under here I think we've
included under here for a long time
because it's not um it's not say the doj
is applying for federal money to do
things at the doj I mean we a segment of
the federal grants we get do that but
most of our Federal grant money comes in
we bring it in we do the work to go and
get it and bring it in and we send it
out and could you just clarify when you
when it comes to litigation settlements
that can be very large amounts of money
in the settlement agreement it's usually
clarified how you're supposed to use the
funds when they come into the state it's
not like everything can go in the
general fund and we can have fun with it
right it's but is there some portion of
settlement funds that are if you could
just sure seems like there's a statute
on that
so 10% of any amount over a million
dollars has to go in the rainy day fund
um and we actually we are pretty
restricted on how we can put
stipulations on any settlement dollars
we get and where those dollars can go
that's a change the legislature made I
think back in 2013 20 2014 it used to be
that if we say went out and sued
somebody let's say we settled for $5
million we could write into the
settlement agreement oh the money has to
be used for this the money has to be
used for that the legislature is
actually
tightened that up and restricted us from
doing that that said the legislature has
decided to send certain settlement
Monies to certain places yeah or
uh the p p settlements for instance I
was wondering you told me before what
you anticipated for that but I don't
remember did you say 30 we we we're
estimating around $65 million and we
actually believe the payments are going
to start coming in pretty soon in the
next month or two I didn't include that
in our recoveries here cuz the money
hasn't actually come in yet but it's
worthy of no yes and that goes to the
drinking water trust fund right so the
legislature has directed where some of
this money goes we at doj for the most
part don't do that okay thank you y all
right let's go to the page um original
agency
request
so um
looks it looks as though my microphone
it looks as though um
you um asked for less money than what
the governor gave you if I'm looking at
page 288 in house bill
one yes and I C I can talk through that
if we we prepared the presentation to
just try to
explain that would you mind if I take a
couple minutes to talk through that okay
so the thank you the the original agency
request as you see here
um didn't include a lot of non-state or
non-federal Grant
funds and so the original agency
requests we really we knew we were
coming into tough budget times we wanted
to focus on you know really the
Department's operation the money for the
Department of Justice is operational
needs that was the original agency
request the next page shows the
governor's adjustments the governor
actually we did actually you know take
some fairly significant reductions in
operations funds we had six generally
funded positions unfunded two federally
funded positions unfunded so that that
money could be repurposed to other
things and restructured some of the drug
task force funding which included
federal funds and general funds
the governor though and and I and I
support this we the unfunded positions
were vacant yes yes okay thank
yep the governor and I discussed some
other priorities though and these are
very important priorities to her but
they Encompass some significant
non-federal grants so they these do not
involve the Department of Justice like
operations for the Department of Justice
but they are money that they are funds
that go into into our budget and so we
have the internet crimes against
children task force there's $800,000 on
top of what we requested the child
advocacy centers and uh victims of crime
supplemental funds for for for various
programs that support Crime Victims
throughout the state I've talked about
that before that comes from something
we've called sort of the the call it the
VCA gap for many years we were getting
Federal grant funds under uh the victims
of crime act the federal victims of
crime act those funds have been
decreasing we had been getting about or
getting enough to spend about $10
million a year on on programs for
victims of crime around the state for
victim services with the federal fund
reduction the governor just recognizing
how important it is to serve victims of
crime uh recognizing these are critical
programs all around the state
supplemented the reduction in those
federal funds with
with General funds so these are not with
maybe exceptions for a very very small
amount of dollars and I'm talking in the
thousands for the most part not dollars
that relate to the operations of the
Department of Justice but they are
appropriated to the Department of
Justice so that we can subgrant them out
can you point out these three things in
house bill one I can do that if you'd
like yeah go ahead uh it's page 243 and
it's class line
73 just the last one yep for the
additions the grants are all in one
class line it's at the bottom oh all
three are together yep I
see page
243 and at the bottom it's class line
073 uhuh BR
[Music]
Federal and if you turn the page there's
a footnote that discusses um the
Appropriations for the internet child
against children and the children
advocacy centers
that's okay so these
are are are these
um victims of crime supplement these
three things are they all brand new or
they used to get little tiny amounts of
of uh General
funds
the the victims of
crime General funds so the the victim
Services General funds these are brand
new we have not before given any general
funds to these programs because it's
been a it's been a ferally funded
effort internet crimes against children
task force the state has been
appropriating General funds for this
for a number of years I think this is
flat funded from before we didn't put it
in our agency requests this year but we
did we did get it in the last bium so
1.3 million is not an increase from the
last by any them and I say 1.3 million
because we had five we had 500,000 in
our request the governor added
800,000 for the child advocacy centers I
think we we had I think 100,000 per year
in our requests the governor added 2.8
million that is consistent though with
an hb2 appropriation from the last
budget so these amounts have gone up
over the years but not they aren't all
this uh this money is not all new money
when you look at the the iak and the and
the cacs okay now you said victims of
crime there's also Federal money as well
is that right yes and what page would
that
be Kathy's going to help me I'll tell
you on the line by line pieces
and by the way what while we're on page
243 um fiscal year 2024 actual has this
giant litigation cost that's $7 million
going down to 350,000 for the next three
years so what's that so that is our
litigation fund so as long as I can
remember the legislature has asked us
we've we've gotten a pretty small amount
in our budget and we come back to fiscal
every year with an estimate of the money
we're going to need for litigation funds
so we've stopped budgeting that because
it's we we it just is it has never been
handled through the budget we get
$350,000 each fiscal year budgeted we
come back to fiscal based on what the
needs are going to be and that really
just depends on what cases end up
Landing with us and how much we need to
make sure we cover it all we decided
years ago that if we put a large Fund in
there it became a target for the people
that wanted to sue the state yeah so if
we put too much money in there oh I can
go get a piece of
that yeah so that's for the last few
years it's been some number between six
and 8 million per per year so does this
strictly pay people when we lose a case
or is this also cover our attorneys to
defend us and all this kind of stuff it
covers out outside councel outside
experts Consultants uh depending on how
complicated the case is that we we may
we may need that okay can you get us a
spreadsheet of like six years worth of
History including details like that how
much was paid to litigant how much uh
was our Council how much was the
different
categories yes we can do that um and I
would
just yeah so yes we will get that for
you and I would just note that by law
we're required to submit that type of
report at the end of every bium so we do
we do submit those types of reports to
the legislature but of course for
purposes of the budget process we'll get
that to you for the last six years more
like a anyway represent W yeah on the
page where you show your recoveries and
you show
8177 977 State debts recovered what
period of time is
that uh 23 and 24 calendar year 23 and
24 that's how much you recovered in just
two years debt that that's from debt
collection so
what they're usually smaller Because by
the time it gets to us for debt
collection it means that whatever other
agency in the state who was going out to
get that money hasn't been able to get
it because perhaps somebody who owes the
state the money is you know uh at that
point and pretty close to destitute or
bankrupt so we often only are able to
recover Pennies on the dollar but we
only have one attorney that does that
work so while it's not a lot the
investment I think is worth it we're
probably spending
$100,000 between1 $150,000 a year on the
attorney we're still getting several
00,000 a year in so it where did that
money go in those years it goes into the
general fund right or no do we keep it
so a portion takes care of paying for
the attorney okay and the rest of it
goes back um a percentage of it goes to
the
agency that um that needed to collect
that debt so it goes to the agency who's
owed that debt so it doesn't like we see
a net positive here very much okay thank
you representative eel yeah I I think
this is what you're saying but I just
want to ask the question again so I'm
looking like on page 43 where it says
grants nonfederal it goes go I don't
know 25 from 450 and then it jumps up to
many several millions of dollars so
that's and then later it's it's General
funds so it's basically this part of
Europe she's added that to replace
Federal funding that is no long is that
that's the story yes so now it's a
general fund appropriation correct of
several million okay or 13 but but I'd
like to see the page where the federal
funding is going down
page 278
okay yeah why don't
you so um we're
we budgeted based on estimates of what
we have left over plus what we're
expecting to get um we try to be very
care we knew these funds were going to
be going down so in 25 we were at 8.68 n
million um we budgeted
6.45 million but that
includes a small we try to be very
careful with our funds to make it spread
out as much as possible so it does
include a little bit of money that we
plan
on supplementing the loss um we're
expecting
between probably a three to four million
doll loss in federal funds um but when
you get your federal funds they're
always in multiple years so um we try to
spend them spread the money out um to
serve as many victim Services as we can
so they can serve the
victims so to me this looks flat this
doesn't look like it's
declining right well in four and eight
and get 12 and I had six and six and get
12 and you know so it's
so it's it's we actually spent
4.2 yes um that wasn't what we were
budgeted um for 24 25 um we had 8.6 so
if you compare 25 to 26 it went down
like 2.2 million and and just to add to
that I think I I think what we'll get to
your question representative is
that the the federal fund so the federal
funds
budgeted in 24 and 25 well actually no
never mind I'm missing that yeah yeah so
that it's the same Federal number so do
you think that that what's in the budget
for 25 is inaccurate and when we
actually get to the end of 25 it won't
be 8
million it'll be more like 4 point
something
or so the actual expense is not what we
contracted out what we subg granted out
the actual expense is what our subg
grantees had spent in that year we can
only pay them once they report to us
what they spent um so that's what we
ended up um
reimbursing those um nonprofits and um
other victim Services um we we budget
what we need to commit so even though
that's our actual expense
we had to BR we brought those subg
grants forward so we could continue to
reimburse okay who gets this
money so um we can get you a whole list
of of the there is a large list of
victim services that receed this money
and we'll I'll make sure to write that
down and get you a list yeah we I mean
we've got the list so we'll just send it
to you I mean I've got I've got it right
here but we can send you a list but it
is just for just a some examples it's
County attorney offices so the county
attorney offices will use this to pay
for victim advocates in the office it's
the Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence and money will will go
out to all the various crisis centers
around the state it's the child advocacy
centers so the child advocacy centers
also get some of this money in addition
to to separate money uh organizations
like Catholic Charities do do work with
victims Casa uh some cities
municipalities if they're paying for
victim advocates in their police
departments it's a it's a wide range of
different organizations but it's all
pretty much all either government loc
local government or or nonprofit who are
doing work for for
victims so we can get you the full list
I have it right here we can send it to
you yeah yeah so it's it's like shelters
as opposed to a victim's not getting a
check right it's it's more
like a victim is in out of their home
and then they're in the shelter or
something like this right so it's it's
that it's a victim ad you know victim
Advocates that'll fund a victim Advocate
position who helps a victim navigate the
criminal justice system as their case is
going through Court there are programs
that provide sort of maybe some
temporary housing assistance for victims
in certain situations but that's not
where most of this money goes but I I
wouldn't want to say that there are no
instances in where some of this money
goes directly to a victim but it that's
not really the primary purpose of of
this money it's to it's more for
services for that victim people who help
a victim as they navigate the criminal
justice system or as that victim tries
to access other services that they're
that they're eligible for you have
someone there who who helps them do that
I see okay
um great how do you decide who gets
what yes yes so we do an RFP process we
have applications come in from
organizations around the state our
grants management unit goes through uh a
process to evaluate all those look at
what they're proposing to use the
funding for recommendations come to me I
look at them I sign off on them we do
Grant agreements we take it through the
governor and executive counsel so
there's a there's a long process
involved for deciding who gets what and
a lot of eyes on it and how much is
expenses for all
that is there several full-time people
or we we
have let me just make sure I get these
numbers right it's grants we have a
grants management unit that manages all
of our
grants not just the yeah so not just the
the is this the biggest Services
Grants yeah yeah this is their total
budget not all of them do don't yeah but
there what do we have four full-time in
the grants management unit six six
full-time in the grants management unit
six full-time
employees but one of one of the
functions that
they that they provide which I think is
really important and it's important to
understand for the grants and this is
pretty consistent with a lot of grants
the state gives out we don't just write
a check for 250,000 bucks and send it
out to an organization we say to an
organization once it's approved you now
have a grant for
$250,000 but the money is dispersed on a
reimbursement basis where we're
continuing to review what they're doing
the expenses they're incurring and we're
reimbursing for those expenses that
takes a lot of time and effort so that
that's part of what the staff and the
grants management unit do they also
manage all the applications they're
always on the lookout for other grants
that the state could potentially go out
and get yeah so this is the five people
on page
270 well there's
one so there's five per and temporary oh
no five permanence and one temporary oh
and there's more on victim Services I
see another three on page
271 no well 265 and another uh
yeah and some people in 272 269 yeah I
see there's a whole bunch here okay yeah
all
right so it might be helpful to have
grants as a whole a separate spreadsheet
and and again with historical
information right each one historical
expenses for Grants something like that
yeah okay any other questions on this
area no we're good
okay all
right all right this is good
so uh last page here or is this
um
yeah with additional grants without
additional grants I see all right one
thing we've heard heard from some other
um Commissioners is that the governor at
some point asked them to
prepare um even further reduced budgets
than their basic budget and and did they
ask you to do that kind of
thing yes okay and um did those
reductions make it into the final budget
or not yes all of the reductions we
prepared for the governor made in to our
budget okay because I've heard from some
others that that was not the case yeah
it it may be but and I I can't sit here
and represent to you that the reductions
we were asked to prepare were as large
as reductions other agencies were asked
to prepare but what I can confirm is
that the reductions that we were asked
to repair all made it into the budget
gotcha okay and from this it looks like
except for the
grants you are spending less yeah yes
yeah okay now are you so of your however
many uh positions let's let's look at
that
um 20 all so you have
positions um I'm on page
288 so you have uh 196 positions 131 are
unclassified I'm assuming those are all
attorneys attorneys investigators
victim witness
Specialists uh medical examiners and
there's uh about half that number are
regular assist classifi positions yeah
yes okay now that seems
like like a high very high ratio of of
chiefs to Indians I guess if you want to
do you know what I mean um because I
think about like the Judiciary right
where there's one judge five staff or
something like that rather than here
it's it's two attorneys for one staff
yeah has it always been like this is it
that is so
if yeah in any law firm it's very common
to have you know more attorneys than
than support staff so interesting for
one I'd say the breakdown between
unclassified and
classified we we might be
may not be the highest percentage of
unclassified of any agency but we're
certainly one of the highest every
lawyer is an unclassified position but
that goes all the way from the most
Junior lawyer in the office who may have
a year or two of experience to to me the
the attorney general or you know there
certain there are people in the office
obviously have many more years in in the
law that than I do so every lawyer is
unclassified so it that's different than
most agencies throughout state
government usually in an agency in state
government it's only the most people who
tend to be unclassified all of our
lawyers are unclassified all of our
investigators are unclassified even from
the least experienced to the most all of
our victim witness Advocates from the
least experienced to the most it's just
it's a unique we are a we are a unique
agency in that sense okay and so how
many of these are vacant and unfunded
and that's thr
stuff so
do you want to know the
unfunded yeah start with vacancies and
then I how many of those are funded and
how many are not
yeah
six six that we vacant eight that are
vacant unfunded so eight vacant unfunded
and what are our total vacancies is it
22 but does the 22 include the
eight uh no
okay but some of these are part time so
we oh some part time
yeah yeah I I believe I mean we'll the
numbers I have here I think we have 22
total vacancies out of
213 temporary and permanent
positions does this number include part
no okay the 213 does not include
part-time positions so we have
213 full-time temporary and permanent
positions 22 of those are
vacant eight of those were unfunded in
the governor's
budget that's
okay 2 yeah out of the 213 yes out of
the
okay all
right so
um the other two general questions I
have is I want I want to ask about the
the YDC lawsuit status and I remember um
the last two years ago um you said to us
we you have sovereign immunity and you
can decide who can sue you and how for
details right
um could
we um require all the victims to use the
settlement process and not suest in
court I I think the way I interpret that
question is B basically could we could
we change the law such that we we don't
wave sovereign immunity to any extent so
that anyone who falls in the category of
of the victims who who have sued the
state would not get a claim against the
state in court their only option would
be use the settlement
fund we may face I'm going to be a
little I want to be careful in in
answering a question like this well it
depends and and and here's the thing the
reason I'm going to be careful in
answering a question like this is
because if you were to decide to make a
change like that or a similar change
like that and then we get sued about
that of course have to defend that
action so I don't want to sit here and
say if you do XYZ that's illegal but um
we we may face challenges if we did that
it it depends and it depends to what
extent the legislature were to attempt
to do that okay
um but you wouldn't refuse to defend Us
in that circumstance or I don't know I
mean is it how can how can you do is it
is it a can you say we're 90% likely to
win such a case or 10% likely or or it
doesn't work that way the advice I would
I would give you and I would want to do
it in an attorney client privilege
setting and not in public is whether I
think there's a colorable argument at
least just a a colorable non-frivolous
argument that we could make to defend an
action the legislature was was going to
take because as long as we can meet that
threshold we would always defend it okay
the other part about the yedc I wanted
to ask about is as I understand the way
the process or the law that we passed
works is that um of the of the payments
um 2third go to the victim and one/ thir
goes to their attorneys is that
something we can change or
not yes that that's something we could
change in the statute and the the one
the one clarification I would say to
that is that what the statute says is
that the attorney fee can't be more than
a third right which I think is important
and we do try to to reemphasize and and
the administrator has awarded fees in
some cases Le less than a third so a
third is is the maximum I see the
additional factor that to keep in mind
is that to the extent a claimant or or a
victim has a separate agreement with an
attorney on the
side we we can't really control that so
once once the the claimant has their
money if they had a separate agreement
with the attorney that the attorney
would get more and they decide to honor
that agreement and pay it to the
attorney it's not something that the
state can control I see yeah I've heard
of cases where attorneys are lending
money to to victims and then they have
separate agreements on how they get paid
back and things like that yeah okay um
the reason I'm asking that particular
question is we hear from the uh
Judiciary and I assume the same thing is
true in your office that just the sheer
volume of these cases is costing a lot
of um expense and so um I'm looking for
a way to to somehow share that
expense um with the uh other parties
right so um now and then the last
question I want to ask about this the
governor did not put the ongoing 75
million a year into the budget
so to what extent are we obligated to do
that I mean it the what what I remember
from two years ago was that we sort of
made that agreement that you know for
the next 10 years we're going to put 75
million a year in the budget to cover
this
expense so the the the first part of the
answer to that question is the
legislature is not legally obligated to
to continue to put 75 million in per
year um the second part of the answer to
that question is just to a reminder that
the 75 million is is a cap it's an
annual cap it's not a floor so it's an
annual cap it's the number up to which
the administrator can authorize payments
so I could see why the legislature you
know some legislators might say well if
if the cap is 75 million we'll budget 75
million but you're certainly not
required to do that but you're also not
required to continue to put to put the
money in
I think there there was a um part of the
reason for putting in the annual cap was
to say as long as we continue to do this
fund we at least know we're not going to
put in more than 75 million per year and
I think the 10 years stems from well if
we keep this fund going for all of the
claimants that we expect to file claims
that might be the period of time over
which we need to spread these payments
out and keep this fund going that does
not mean though that the legislature has
legally obligated itself to continue
that and in fact I think is just as is
discussed all the time in the
legislature one legislature generally
can't bind another right can't require a
future legislature to make certain
Appropriations and we did not at the
Department of Justice sign any type of
binding legal document that would bind
the state to that type of obligation
well but on the other hand when you make
a settlement with somebody don't both of
you sign some kind of agreement for
individual cases yes right so once we
have made an award to an individual
claimant the state is bound to that okay
but we are not bound to continue to fund
potential Awards to to claimants that
haven't got actually gotten an award yet
oh are you saying that um we're only
settling with people with money we
already have allocated and so therefore
suppose the next guy down the list wants
to settle do we say sorry we can't
settle yet because the fund is empty yes
we and and and the administrator and I
have discussed this I mean if if we
think the funds are going to run out or
have run out and we can't fund further
settlements we're not just going to
continue to make further Awards or enter
into further individual settlement
agreements yeah we're not going to do
that okay so everybody who settled the
money is there for
them everybody who's settled so far so
far the yes the money is there with with
this caveat right so to the extent that
we've had some people set get Awards
let's say a million dollar award paid
out over eight years
sure if the fund runs out and we don't
make any more settlements there may need
to be some amount of money put in in the
future in the future to make sure we
fulfill those obligations so I can't say
that every single
dime is in the fund to be enough to pay
those to pay all of those out but it
wouldn't be a large amount of money if
we sto today if we sto today I I could
Envision even in a couple years needing
to put a little more money in to
continue to honor those ongoing
agreements
okay a representative camell thank you
Mr chair so how much is in the fund
right now and did you collect the 75
million for this year
already no so we we were appropriated or
the fund I should say was appropriated
$60 million for this current fiscal year
there which at the time this fiscal year
started the fund was about at zero so
that we basically started the fiscal
year with that 60 million there is uh
depending on how you calculate it 26 to
29 million remaining in the fund as of
today
okay and I would when you say he you
mean the
administrator yeah he's on our schedule
for today but I would
which oh
okay so it looks like it's actually 32.3
million is available 32.3 and a half
pending okay yeah so with five and a
half pending so it's actually more like
it's 27 million like like I said
depending on how it's a significant
amount of money yes yes we are not we're
not on the verge of running out at this
moment okay at this moment so are you
finding that
that many victims are not inclined to go
the settlement
routes I mean can you
tell I would say the pace of or the the
the um the rate at which victims are
filing the settlement fund has increased
I think we have over
th just over a thousand victims have now
filed in in the settlement fund oh so
the rate has significantly increased but
a lot of those filings are more recent
so it so it takes a while for the whole
process to oh yeah it would take a while
to get through all thousand of those I
think we've resolved somewhere between
250 and 300 originally your estimate was
that 1,500 would would end up be being
involved is that still
correct as we sit here given I don't
mean in settlement I mean as either in
cases or in settlements
yeah yes I would say as we sit here
today that estimate I I still think is
is pretty close to to the ballark given
that it's just over a thousand and the
deadline is going to be June 30th the
deadline to file is June 30th and we
still we we have not hit the 1500 number
in lawsuits filed in court so I I think
1,500 around that would still remain my
estimate but if the pace really picks up
right at the end it could end up being
more now do people both file in court
and file for a
settlement many have filed in both
because many started out by filing
lawsuits in court but if you have a
pending lawsuit and then you file a in
the settlement fund you have to pause
your lawsuit while your settlement fund
process plays out and then if you accept
what you get in the settlement fund your
lawsuit goes away I see thank you did I
see a hand
no all right representative wer why did
we stretch out the
deadline thought it was going to be the
end of last
year I I sort of remember that the
administ asked for that right yeah it
was part of the dis so when you know the
deadline the deadlines now been extended
a couple of times and changes have been
made to the fund you know based on
discussions with claimant's Council and
the administrator and and our office and
and and the governor's office
um that there it was look it was a
compromise right so we've had a couple
couple different compromises as we've
gone through this process and the last
round of discussions the last compromise
that resulted from the last round of
discussions involved extending the
settlement fund deadline by 6
months representative camell thank you
Mr chair do you think it's likely
they're going to ask for another
extension there could be a request for
another extension and I'm I am perfectly
comfortable saying publicly that putting
aside every other point that we we've
discussed about the settlement fund and
what might happen I would absolutely
recommend against any more extensions if
we're going to M if we are going to
maintain the settlement fund and that's
a discussion that has to continue to be
had with with the governor and the
legislature we absolutely should not
extend the deadline again at some point
a decision has to be made there has to
be a deadline that comes and goes so we
have a sense of what the full scope of
this is so that that is my
recommendation that we should not extend
the deadline again follow up Mr chair
yes sir so um that would basically lock
out people from filing for the for the
fund that we've established it doesn't
prevent anybody from suing in the future
anyway right correct thank
you okay all right um the other item I
have on my sort of general questions
list we have a member of our committee
who's very concerned about uh
Dei uh diversity equity and inclusion
and president Trump just recently made a
a executive
order cancelling all that kind of stuff
from the federal government are you
aware of any of that in either in your
department or in the state
generally those kind of initiatives or
those kind of I I'm not aware of
anything within our department that
would fall within the scope of what's
covered by the president's executive
order and we're we're working with all
of the agencies across state government
as we typically do whenever there's a
new requirement or prohibition to look
at the various programs people have
whatever grants they have whatever other
contracts they have to make sure that
there that there's nothing that would be
inv violation of the president's
executive order um I'm not going to sit
here and say I think we have none or we
have no contracts or programs or grants
that that you know would would fall
within the scope of the president's
executive order but I don't think it's
going to be a large amount at the end of
the day and we're going to be working
closely with agen genes to make sure
that we don't have anything that is out
of compliance okay on an ongoing basis
yes yeah and the state does a lot of
things so you there's no way to answer
or do an analysis like that overnight
but we're working hard to get our arms
around it and make sure we stay in
compliance with any federal or state
requirements
okay all right
so we're kind of out of yes go ahead
represent view I know you have a lot
well no but we're I'm going to say we're
about out of time time just could you
clarify what the statute of limitations
is for the YDC CL cases to file in
Superior Court how the statute of
limitations Works in that is that will
that take another 10 minutes it it won't
take 10 minutes I wish it were a a
simple answer but it it's not so um so
for someone who who had a claim that
that arises when they're a child
typically the statute limitations or the
the the black and white statute
limitations would be 3 years from that
person's 18th birthday but there's
something called The Discovery rule
which says that the statute doesn't
start to run until that point at which
you either did discover or should have
through reasonable diligence discovered
your injury and so this this is an this
is a fact specific inquiry for every
individual case so while all of the
claimants pretty much that have sued the
state sued long after 3 years from their
18th
birthday so far as we've litigated these
cases the court has said we have to do a
statute limitations analysis for every
individual case to determine whether the
discovery rule saves that individual
lawsuit so there is no easy an easy
broad Strokes answer to that question
unfortunately representative Le uh
before the attorney General leaves uh
obviously the Human Rights Commission is
kind of under your jurisdiction and you
are aware of the audit and they're
coming before us uh I believe next do
you have any comments how we should
proceed with the Human Rights Commission
since they're kind of in embedded in
your
department so I I was planning to stay
for that and the the settlement fund
presentation just because I figured you
may have questions but but I will I'll
take a quick shot at answering that
they're they're not really embedded
Within our department they are
administratively attached to us which
means we handle we help them with some
HR and payroll and other sort of
administrative things U but but in
addition to that I will say we are
councel for all agencies in state
government so we do have a lawyer that's
assigned to them to to help work through
these issues so I I'm aware of the
issues there's a lot there that needs to
be worked on we we take it very
seriously and and we want to work
through it but um but they're not
they're not I wouldn't say they're
embedded with us or under our
jurisdiction because at the end of the
day we might file at least a someone
who's not their counil in the office
might be filing claims in the Human
Rights Commission so they're they're
this they're a separate quasi
adjudicative body so they're not
embedded within the
doj let me follow up with a slightly
more general question because we have a
number of these kind of of agencies
right we've got the btla we've got h
we've got the pension the um employee
relations uh board and all these kind of
things that are these quas judicial
things and I think in all cases people
could go to court if they wanted to or
they can go that way right um is your
general and from what we can tell
financially the the they're very
expensive they're not that cheap per
case in in terms of our expenses there
may be cheap per case in terms of not
having an attorney and and and filing
fee kind of things but but often these
these little boards are their expenses
can be $110,000 a case or something like
that so do you find do you have any
impression about how valuable these kind
of things are or not do you anything you
want to say about them sure
um just just as a general matter one of
the reasons to have some of these more
specialized boards is so that you have
um people adjudicating the cases who
have an expertise in in a area that
might be unique right courts obviously
have to deal with every type of case so
I think one of the reasons these types
of boards exist is for specialization
that said there could my impression is
there are probably some efficiencies
that that could be gained there but it's
something that I would be very to really
oine on off the top of my head but it
may especially as the governor is
undertaking these efficiency efforts
with the commission on government
efficiency I mean that type of thing I
think is a topic that that we could that
we as a as a state could be could be
looking at thank you so I think next
thank you very much so um let me talk to
Melissa we may or may not have to ask
you back but I'm I'm definitely going to
try to
get your data in a form that makes it
easier for us to see the history
absolutely and and happy to provide
feedback in response to any follow-up
written questions that often is is a
very good way for us to make sure we're
getting you the information you you'd
like to see yes thank you very much okay
so let's take a couple of minutes and uh
I want to talk to Melissa and then we'll
who is coming next is it human rights
yes okay
good
e
e e
so we're back on page
288 I guess we're
we'll be back out of recess I
guess on page 288 we have the Human
Rights
Commission representative Maguire yes um
are we missing human rights person isn't
here yet they thought they were coming
at
2:45 oh
um Kathy can speak to the budget if you
want straight budget
questions from doj she she's prepared to
speak to those but she wouldn't have the
details of any maybe of the audit
questions yeah just our our usual
questions there's 15 people or any
unfunded you
know yeah this I printed for
you I also email
yeah okay
okay
so apolog time wrong yeah apologies for
this um there was an initial email that
had gone out that had a different
sequence of events and
um so um Katrina tayor who is the acting
assistant director is was planning on
the 2:30 time frame so she'll be she
will be here so but I'm happy to answer
any questions on the budget okay so
there's 15 people um are any of these
vacant and or unfunded yes so if um that
we ended up we stayed Rel relatively
flat for the budget um we ended up
unfund a full-time secretary and a
part-time secretary position um and that
saved about uh
94,000 in 26 and 98,000 in 27 and then
they were partially they had a little
small those two positions had federal
funds to help also so those went away um
and then we did an offset of the general
funds um so the federal fund net was a
net increase um of what was estimated
that the federal funds would be that
they would receive um so it ended up
reducing the um general
fund by about
75,000 in 26 and about 20 something in
right in uh 27 and I'm guessing there's
several vacant or at least there were in
2024 because so I had um sent out a
vacancy list um there's two three four
five so there's five uh
full-time
positions and one part-time position
that is vacant at the
moment
okay do you know in terms of the number
of cases they get per
year um how many they they get new ones
and how many they close Old
ones I do not have that
um current the current information okay
for
that but we can send it to you if I
could Mr chairman they have I've got the
audit that fiscal looked at a week or
two ago and they've got like 259 cases
pending uh how many
or file each year doesn't say but they
do have 259 pending and some of them are
older than two years
yeah yeah so I I like to know the flow
kind of more than
the because some of them could be quite
old right so yeah there quite a few that
are okay
um and they're in RSA 354a apparently is
that right
so I haven't um had a chance to look at
that audit so what I just hear it's so
horrible so what specifically has
happened on
it
microphone a lot of the cases took
almost three years and then there was a
section in the back where the people
that had appeared before it were asked
to appear to to write it criticism and
there were several that said you know it
was worthless going there because you
lost the time lawyer someone would ask
for a lawyer the lawyer would file the
case there some of them would say if I
haven't heard anything in a year I'll
file them in the court because otherwise
after three years you can't file so then
you've exceeded the statute of
limitation so from one of the the
criticism where everything was took too
much time he might file a case and not
here for a year whether anything was
done and then two years go by and now
they're finally calling for Witnesses
and they don't even interview all the
witnesses that were put in the in the
claim so there was a lot of complaints
about incomplete and and uh hastiness
and and lots of delays so and Justice
delayed is Justice denied that kind of
thing that state I'd like to add that
20% of their cases went beyond the
threeyear
statute of limitations which preluded
those
petitioners from going to
court thing was really counterproductive
to what it was intended to do
so is this one of those things where
um you get to decide when you have a
such a case you either go Superior Court
or you go here and from here you can go
to the Supreme Court is that the or
super period yeah I mean to appeal if
somebody wants to appeal yeah okay all
right um and it how many what fraction
of their cases they do both housing and
employment right was like almost 90%
were
employment mostly employment
okay I think he's got if he's got it
there is he's got the the the
diagram there a circle diagram showing
how many yeah I can chairman wer is
correct uh housing accounted for nine
cases 3.5
% public accommodations 20
cases public education three cases
employment
227 cases I see I see I see gotta so
it's almost all employment okay
um yeah
so
clearly it seemed to me thinking about
this that
um the Attorney General is really
not overseeing these people right I mean
it's like administratively attached
they're just sort of I want to go get my
copy of the the audit okay and so I mean
we
could and and clearly something should
be done with to make it better right so
well there was an attorney that was uh
they sent out requests for comments from
different people and there was one
particular comment that
struck me that one attorney had been
practicing before them for as many as 20
years and his comments where um the
commission's investigation process has
been in my opinion terrible in the past
years and he said he's been practicing
or she before them for 20 years so this
has been a long on ongoing problem and
again as it LBA pointed out the cost is
millions of dollars for and yeah yeah
it's some point you know changes
obviously need to be made or yeah right
so so the first decision is do we want
this you know non-judicial judicial
function to exist right do we or do we
we just want to say to these people go
to court right which is their option
which yes representative evil so I guess
the thing that I struggle with is if the
failure of the commission to do the work
it needs to
do is because they are
chronically
underfunded because I I just remember
them coming in there you know the
director was trying to do secretarial
duties or you know there was just a lot
of and so it's hard to unwind how much
the The Chronic
underfunding uh is the cause of these
problems and how much just their
management skills are part of the
problem I mean I it's it's really hard
for us to unwind those two things so if
one of the arguments is underfunding and
if they've been underfunded by millions
of dollars how much money would it
actually take to get them so they were
functioning and it might
be way more than than we have I mean
maybe you guys have an opinion on that
but that's just what I I hate to really
call them on the carpet if they haven't
G been given the tools to do what they
need to do I believe in the last budget
we gave them more than they had
requested because it was one of their
prioritized needs to have at least four
additional people now whether those
people were hired or not but we did
provide more investigative funding yeah
so the question even then was you know
they had to dig themselves out of such a
hole but anyway I just wanted to to
raise that sure
okay so so my so the first question
is we can say to these just get rid of
it and then people go to court right
which is sort of the normal they could
also go to the federal equal employment
opportunity commission which is the
federal funds that come in when they
finish a case they do get money from the
equal employment opportunity commission
but anyone could go to them initially is
that right no
okay or Court okay or
Court I guess it well this is probably
one of those situations where it's both
against federal law and against state
law to discriminate right and so
somebody could decide I'm going fed
versus I'm going state right so yeah
yeah but the whole the whole idea of
this this group right this division was
to speed things up all right and make it
less costly speed it up so you wouldn't
have to go to court and you wouldn't
have to get in line and wait and based
on the audit report and the history of
it it's just the opposite they're
actually taking so long that 20% of
their cases end up end up being
precluded from going to court because
the statue of limitations is run so we
have a group here or a division here
that's counterproductive to the reason
they were originally set
up so an interesting fact Mr chairman is
uh on page 14 of the audit as of
February of
2025 the commission had
21 authorized positions of which 12 were
vacant
so why they not filling those positions
is obviously leading to the delays
perhaps I think
it's maybe yeah okay so and out of the
21 positions six were added by the
legislature in 20124 so there were six
we gave them six new positions not four
as I said earlier well but in the book
it says 15 I know that's why there's
obviously some not there's a mix up
there somewhere but I guess so there's
there's some temporary part-time
positions that they may be including
um there were a few temporary part-time
not full-time you're right positions and
those are not included there also some
criticism of the investigators didn't
know how to
investigate yeah so you're right if you
look on page 289 on line 50 um it looks
like we budged it 130,000 for um for
temps in the last budget and they only
used 30 right so there's a lot of people
they could have hired for that as
well okay well so so again the one
choice is get rid of it tell people to
go to court um the other would be to to
put them under the agis of somebody else
right
who and and so that they could have a
boss right and they could have somebody
who's um who's running it um who who
could be uh related and maybe be a
better management um person over the
this activity
um yes so the two I thought of that's
one right one is the Labor Department
right most of these cases have to do
with labor um I spoke to the Labor
Commissioner he would be willing to take
this on as a as a task um and presumably
we do it in a way that he can uh hire
the people he wants to hire to to do
this job
um but uh that's one possibility the
other one that occurred to me as we were
going through our hearings was the um
that Labor Relations
Board um they have that board that does
uh um labor cases right but those are
those are
um those are union type type cases right
and these are discrimination maybe it's
not as great a fit it's just my
impression of that board was I really
liked their structure their structure of
that board is that they have those nine
experts
right three attorneys three of this and
three three labor experts and three of
that and whenever they decide a case
they say okay give me one attorney give
me one labor expert give me one of these
right and those three people form a
little board to decide a case and and it
seemed to me that was a very efficient
way to do things but that particular
group had four employees and they're
only doing like a 100 cases a year so
seemed to me they were a little um
overstaffed
for for the workers part of it right so
that they might have with with some
additions they might have some extra
capacity so that that was the other
possibility that or the labor department
if we wanted to
continue this um this activity you know
give it another shot basically send them
to the feds yeah or send them to yeah
just say no right I mean you
know
yeah okay
hi we're sorry about the timing the
scheduling problem no I'm very sorry
very sorry no it's our fault I think so
so good afternoon uh my name is Katrina
Taylor thank you for this opportunity um
I am temporarily the acting assistant
director um so I was just here to
present on behalf of Annie who could not
be here today um so I'm happy I don't
know how far you've gotten but happy to
answer yeah we've been talking about the
the audit that came out of your agency
and um do you want to respond I mean it
it it shows a lot of problems basically
so I unfortunately can't respond on
behalf of the commission I know I can
say that on behalf of current staff and
myself and the Commissioners that I've
spoken to we've already taken many steps
to address some of the things that were
brought up in the audit even before the
audit report came out um so we have
already gone underway with that um we
absolutely agree with many of the
recommendations and we really think we
are confident uh that we could achieve
that okay um now why have you been um
you you you have 15 um U positions
available but but you're you're only at
like two-third
strength yes so most of these vacancies
became vacant before I became Act in
assistant director so I have put in
hiring waiver requests as um with the
commissioner's approval um to fill these
positions because once again I believe
fully staffed we are going to you'll see
a significant change in how things are
processed but this the the these have
been in the budget at least a year and a
half already they were full yes filled
every right so all of the positions were
filled at one time except for one um
vacancy dates are
May last May October two in
October pass yeah one in December and
one in June um so they were all at one
time full except for one position um I
just wanted to so in that case when
they're full why do we have some cases
going on for years so again I want to go
back to the backlog that was referenced
in the audit report um there was a Mis
clarification I think because there are
no cases from the 1980s that are
currently open with the commission I
want to make that very clear um a
backlog which means an a list of cases
waiting to be assigned uh that's what we
Define as a backlog has existed since
before I was born um so that was a
historical issue now when the more cases
come in and when our budget got cut I
believe it was in 2011 they were down to
for investigators so they already had a
backlog and then the staff was cut and
then we were able to get some more staff
thank you um and we've seen a reduction
but we obviously keep getting a flurry
of cases um our case numbers have gone
up over 60% in the past five years um
just as an example for this year alone
we do statistics federally by our
federal fiscal year so I go October to
September so we're we're only four
months through and we have already had a
third of cases filed this year than we
had total in 2024 so the number of cases
that are coming in is a significant
number it's still they're coming in and
we are processing them as best as we can
all right how many cases came in in 2024
in
2024 I think I have that on me I want to
say
285 yeah all total 285 were filed in
2020 and how many were closed
243 okay and how much um hours of work
does a typical case take I don't know if
I could put a qualitative number on it
because it's a caseby casee basis the
problem that we that I've seen in my
historical time with the commission um
is the length of time that is the
problematic is that time that it's
waiting to to get assigned to someone so
we docket it right away we process it we
notice uh the respondent and then that
sitting process is the year and the half
process that's usually referenced um
because we're processing those um case
uh my investigators they process cases
they get an evolving case load it's not
like they close 25 in a year and they're
done they constantly as soon as they
close some they're getting more it's
just constant um so the investigation
part could take anywhere from two months
to 12 months on average um if cause is
found then it goes to a legal procedure
which could lengthen the St state of the
case so why why two months I mean two
months it all depends on the case that's
if both parties might agree to settle
the case when an investigator gets
assigned they're like maybe we don't
want to keep producing documentation
maybe we don't want to extend this any
longer maybe we can resolve this we get
a lot of that when it first gets
assigned to an
investigator um it could be a matter of
there's enough evidence there to say hey
yes this is probable cause we need to
move it forward or vice versa that
there's no evidence and it's very
apparent when you first get that case
Okay sometimes there's an attorney that
would like to file an amendment uh they
would like to request documentation they
request extensions proa parties request
extensions as well um and we've been in
historically pretty lenient on allowing
those things to happen
does the most of the claimants have
attorneys or no I don't I wouldn't say
most um a good portion do but I think
the reason why they come to us is
because they don't need an attorney to
go through our process it's much more
clearcut than a court process is okay
and and all right just a moment and and
one last question you so you're saying
that your your um backlog grew by 42
cases in 2024 how much is the backlog
today uh as of today because like I
mentioned that increase um our backlog
is up to
395 okay there was over 100 cases filed
in just the month of November this uh
this past
yearz um say mostly employment uh that
month it was public accommodation was
the number one um but generally we do
mostly employment um because especially
with our EEOC contract
and um all right uh representative wer
then representative Camp what's the most
common U comp point on the employment
charges and how are they usually
resolved in regards to on the basis as
in disability
age is that what what's most common
disability discrimination is most common
I would say what was that disability
discrimination yes and how was it
usually resolved uh that all depends on
the parties so I see we have a great
mediation program um we resolve at least
probably 30 to 40 cases just with that
program alone per year um so that's
voluntary settlement my investigators
also facilitate settlement
discussions um but those are resolved
through investigation we'll have to
determine the legal standard if somebody
you know asked for a reasonable
condation that was denied whether that
was
reasonable um and that would either be a
no cause or a probable cause is this the
sort of thing like you're asking me to
carry 50 pounds up two flights for an
example yes and you have a doctor's note
that says you could not do that okay so
person either doesn't get that Duty or
gets another Duty right that would be
considered potentially reasonable
representative Camal thank you Mr chair
you mentioned that you were working the
department was working to fix issues
before the audit and and as a result of
some of the inputs of the audit do you
have a formal corrective action plan
plan and that's something that we can
see uh so we can see what the issues
were and what your corrective actions
are for that so it is my belief that the
executive director is was planning on
submitting such or responding to such
and she is on leave so I do know that
the com current Commissioners are in
discussions about the response to do
that um I don't currently have the
authority because I wasn't there for you
know in management during this audit
period
go ahead so it is there a corrective
action plan going on right now I mean I
can attest to things that we've been
doing in office we've updated our
training manuals we've done more of a
comprehensive internal making sure our
resources are updated making sure our
legal resources are updated um I am in
the process of working with our attorney
general's office to um update our
administrative rules as well I'm
unfamiliar with how that process works
so I'm looking to learn that within the
next week or so okay my experience in
industry is that rather than do the
whack-a-mole approach is you have a
formal corrective action plan that way
everything is documented and you don't
repeat the same mistakes and you so I I
would highly is my understanding that
the Commissioners who again they have
the oversight I believe they are working
on that okay thank you representative
lean thank you Mr chairman U welcome so
some of the items do date back to 20
2008 like one of the concerns was the
members weren't filing financial
statements which still haven't been done
uh which is troubling to me that we all
have to file financial statements and
and yet the commission appears to be
lacking in that way but more to the
point um and to some of the other
questions what other options do people
have if the New Hampshire Human Rights
Commission isn't there can they go to
the federal government can they go to
court for instance Superior Court and
file a complaint there so as our statute
is written um and first of all I'm sorry
I cannot attest to anything the
Commissioners anything managerial
unfortunately I can't speak too um I can
answer your question about where folks
could go if an employer has 15 or more
employees they could file potentially
with the federal government with the
equal employment opportunity commission
um if they have a housing complaint so
anything so New Hampshire I'm sorry just
to clarify New Hampshire's log in
discrimination um protects in employees
with six or more so in New Hampshire you
need six or more employees to file a
complaint um for housing they could file
uh with the with HUD um I do not believe
there is an alternative as of right now
the way their statute's written for
public educ I'm sorry for public
accommodation I believe public education
you have the opportunity to go straight
to Superior Court so or the Department
of Education I believe so there would be
other options without changing statute
without changing statute for certain
things so right now our statute um
requires the administrative exhaustion
you are required to file with us and
then you may remove your case to court
okay thanks thank you Mr chairman
representative evil so um yeah just sort
of following along his thought chain so
if you have so the federal statute
statute says that if you have 15 or more
employees you can go to the EEOC our
statute says if you have six or more so
there's obviously a gap there so if the
HRC didn't
exist that group of people wouldn't have
recourse except to go to court or no
recourse unless the statute was amended
right now the way the statute is written
they would still have to file with us so
if there was that not that requirement I
believe they could file in court they
would civil and so the reason that
somebody would choose to come before you
folks is that um going through Superior
Court is more complex and they would
feel the need for an attorney or some
sort of
representation that's generally the
feedback that we've received is that our
process is more uh clear on what the
expectations are and how to go through
it and um mostly it is more timely the
investigative process is still more
timely than a court trial if you went to
a full
trial and if people come before the
Human Rights Commission and they do want
an attorney do they tend to need go to
the Civil Rights I mean the civil
litigation sort of folks that come
within the judicial Council for
representation or don't you know I'm not
sure just just generally the employment
we have members of the employment bar I
see practice a lot before us okay thank
you do you tell people when they show up
that they're going to wait a year and a
half before you absolutely we say you
know unfortunately due to our processing
and our staffing um it may be quite some
time before your case is assigned
obviously you can reach out at any time
again we offer mediation at any time it
doesn't have to wait till you get
assigned um and we have a nice success
rate on that program and your
understanding of the regular court
process is it's longer than a year and a
half from what I have heard I am not
it's not my you
know gotcha all right other questions no
I just I just have a comment I mean to
the extent that the HRC goes away or
some of the smaller uh appell boards
that we've been talking about it does
put in a larger burden on the courts so
if you pull one threat the sweater might
start to ra unravel a little bit so I
just think when we're talking about
resources are right no no no I know I'm
not all I'm saying is that if we're
talking about these things we have to
think about the whole pie yes and the
effect on the on the courts that are
already struggling okay all right well
thank you very much um Miss Taylor thank
you so much all right so it is
2:45
um have we seen a person from that's you
okay good
you don't look like Miss John T
bradick no it's just going to be talking
about YDC representative Maguire yes I
just wanted to remind the division that
I handed you guys a letter yesterday yes
um it was addressed to attorney John
pela so she'll be referencing that today
so I just wanted to make sure you had it
in your pile for yesterday yes yeah we
received
um um a letter from
Mr Mr bradrick
okay all right so today is
[Music]
thank you so
much all right thanks all right thanks
please uh introduce
yourself good
afternoon my name is Jen Foley I'm
general counsel for administrator brri
and the claims Administration process um
the administrator wishes that he could
have been here today and really
appreciates the invitation uh he has two
hearings with claimants today which he
um performs regularly it's about his
sixth uh um sixth hearing just this week
um so he does that on a weekly basis so
sometimes his schedule's a little bit
tight now is the the budget that runs
your office in here somewhere or not
it's not um the fund itself um pays for
um our operations um that budget um
because we're actually a little bit
hybrid we are employed officially by the
judicial branch even though we operate
separate and independent from the
judicial branch
um and then the uh we put together a
budget and we bring that to the attorney
general himself um who reviews the
budget for our claims Administration
operations and ultimately um we uh those
operations are paid directly from the
fund
itself and how many employees do you
have so we have open position right now
so I want to make sure I'm precise for
you we currently have nine employees and
three Consultants um those nine
employees some are full-time and some
are part-time I'd be glad to walk
through them if that would be helpful
yes okay we have the administrator who
is full-time we have an assistant
administrator Diane niosi who's a
retired judge she is part-time uh we
have two Executive Administrative
Assistant asss we have general counsel
myself I'm full-time the two executive
administr administrative assistants are
both part-time we have a pargal who's
actually with me today she's full-time
we have two administrative assistants um
both are
full-time uh we have a posted position
just posted this week uh for a claims
operations specialist which would be a
full-time
position and uh we have two individual
trauma experts in order to perform the
statutory function uh the purpose of
being trauma informed um in victim
centered process uh and then we have a
consulting firm who assists us with
technology and claims processing
support so do you have you have your
budget as uh the same way we sort of see
it this list of expenses we can
certainly Supply that would you like
that I'd like to see that
sure so I did put together uh a brief
presentation today would you like me to
walk through that yes please
okay do we have copies or no no I'm just
going to give a kind of a verbal um
summary and then we have the the letter
which I'm happy to walk through okay go
ahead
okay so I'm here to give observations
about the status of the fund right now
particularly for fiscal year 2025 and
focusing specifically on the 60 million
um dollars that was um funded um as of
the statutory amendments um I'm also
here to address division one questions
which we received last week so as some
context there's four categories uh that
draw down from the fund one is resolved
claims with awards from the
administrator's final decision he
reviews and evaluates Awards and issues
a decision which is either an award or
not an award the second category of draw
down is resolved claims with agreed upon
amounts through the Attorney General's
office so the Attorney General's office
and claims councel if they're
represented and mostly they are um can
resolve the claim on their own and then
submit that resolution um to our process
for it to be paid under the
fund the third category is that category
because the Attorney General was in
court with with this claimant and they
settled out of court is that kind
of where that second category comes from
a actually the statute itself the
settlement fund statute itself um is an
entire ecosystem of settlement um to
draw folks out of Courts and to come
into the administrative settlement
process so by Statute it lays out
plainly that there are two ways to
resolve a claim through settlement one
is to go through the administrator's
evaluation and two they could otherwise
go before for the Attorney General's
office and directly negotiate a
settlement that way either way the claim
is submitted to our office uh we do
intake make sure the claim fil is
complete um and then this what we call
stipulated agreements um to the extent
that they come up with a negotiated
resolution would come before our office
we review it to make sure all the
essential terms are there um and then we
would approve for payment processing so
the statute itself lays out two uh
Pathways to settlement resolution I see
okay and and do we have a count like
which way we sure do so the uh letter
that was given to the attorney general
earlier this week that we copied you on
um attachment a um not only lays out um
the a projection for the $60 million
which we see is insufficient for fiscal
year 2025 at the end of it it it
identifies a snapshot of our most
recently cly report and it shows us the
claim count of resolutions as of
December 31st 2024 and breaks out the
distinction so I'll give you the numbers
if that would be helpful go ahead so
total claims resolved through the
settlement um with payment through the
fund is
242 as of the end of
2024 148 of those claims were through
the stipulated agreement mutual
agreement directly with the Attorney
General's office 94 of them had gone
through the uh process the resolution
process in front of the administrator
himself if helpful I can make sure to
get a copy of that Cory report to you
yes please so I'm I'm not getting the
numbers right 242 was the count 242 is
the count and the
breakout
148 and um 94 gotcha all right so this
is interesting that the majority is not
through the
settlement office so why is that do you
think well so all claims have to come
through our
office um and the statute um is which I
think was designed well to make sure
there was maximum Pathways to resolve a
claim
quickly so the statute lays out two
Pathways one with the direct
negotiations with the Attorney General's
office and the is through the resolution
proceeding process which involves a
hearing
so why um claimants um uh pursue direct
settlement directly with the Attorney
General's office and are successful in
that road is not something I can speak
to because the administrator is not
involved um with those negotiated
resolutions by Statute um we are
involved in terms of our staff we
receive the claim make sure it's
complete make sure the claim gets in
front of the Attorney General's office
so they have the claim in
totality um and then should a stipulated
agreement come we have to make sure um
that it's it's appropriate it's within
the bounds of an essential terms um so
that we can approve it for payment
processing okay all right so you said
there's two other ways to remove money
from the fund so one of them is your
expenses presumably correct so cost of
operations um which as I said is under
um a budget that's approved by the
Attorney General's office we also
operate through a memorandum of
understanding that the judicial branch
has um uh put together with the attorney
general uh before our operations began
uh which is how that budget and
reimbursement process occurs the fourth
category is the Attorney General's costs
under the settlement fund statute um the
the Attorney General is permitted um to
um to essentially invoice the fund
directly for um costs that are I think
the language is something like not
ordinary they're not ordinary operations
something like that so they have um
outside Council that they have retained
um that assists them in um uh their part
in participating with the claims process
um those dollar numbers on information
and costs are in the quarterly report as
well okay okay and so far you've been
allocating
135 million is that uh the first first
school year 2024 was the fund um
allocated 100 million um and that 100
million um was distributed um in Awards
in the first year uh when the statute
was revised in 2024 last
summer um the statute the legislature
decided um to um identify by Statute $75
million per fiscal year um but did
actual Appropriations or designated
funds of 60
million okay so um okay so and we
understand that you have something like
32 remaining at the moment 32 could you
repeat that 32 million um
so the roughly um we are at
about um slightly over 30 million in
committed funds um so it's somewhere I
think the the by um the administrator by
the um the Attorney General's numbers
that he put in front of you today I
think he said 27 million and we're our
we balance our books together and
coordinate and we would agree that that
is roughly um the remainder of the of
the 60 million as we as we sit here
today we we ran the numbers a a week or
so ago so uh as you can imagine it
shifts but the the letter says you're
going to run out of that by July 1st
somewhere before it's it's right and so
I can walk through those projections if
that would be helpful yeah
okay so attachment a to the letter that
we sent to the Attorney General's office
to make an observation about the $60
million and the projection um as to
whether it would be sufficient this
fiscal year um we took the numbers in
the quarterly report of December 2024
and we looked at existing activity
through February 18th
2025 so about six weeks of activity
about another 30 claims were
resolved um which which generated about
roughly over $10 million in um resolved
award
amounts so we took that that six week
look and assuming which is a very big
assumption um in this Dynamic
environment that that would be the uh
spend moving forward for the remainder
of the quarter and also the remainder of
fiscal
year adding in the actual and projected
costs of both
offices brought the projection to
slightly over 60
million table two we ran as you know
projections are um uncertain uh but
informative when database based um and
in our environment the awards fluctuate
um quite a bit uh depending on the
nature of the abuse in a particular
claim the the frequency the severity all
go into if there is a verified claim
what is the ultimate dollar amount
that's awarded according to the
guidelines that the legislature approved
and it is um impossible for us to
predict which kinds of claims are coming
to us in a given week we take the claims
as they come
so table two um moved forward into
another set of claims that
were close to final resolution right so
we issue final decisions with an award
amount that the claimants can either
accept or not accept once those
decisions are issued most of the time
they're accepted when there are Awards
um and so those are essentially
encumbered funds and so we took a set of
the next set of encumbered funds which
is a set of about nine claims
and that generated um an average you
know instead of a 10 million it would
bring you to 12 almost 13 million as a
um as a uh a benchmark to estimate the
remainder of the fiscal year with so
when you run that set of projections it
brings you to 71 nearly 72 million um so
and this does not account for in other
words this dollar amount does not
account for for a a um of a a um a
bundle of claims that are under
evaluation right now and another words
we have a beginning to the life cycle of
a claim a middle and an end so sitting
here today we have um at least 25 claims
um that are nearing the end and close to
having an issue date and so uh you know
that that it it keeps coming and we have
hearings that are scheduled um weekly
um all the way throughout into July and
we're and we keep scheduling them out as
a resolution pathway um so as those
hearings come um at the end of Once the
hearing day concludes um we have a
timetable that is set by the statute as
to how quickly um an a um decision a
decision needs to come out we need to
evaluate it is it eligible or not what's
the award if there is one what's the
payout for term of years um and so we
accounting for um how many hearings that
are already scheduled these numbers do
not account for how many more may be
coming we just took a an average um to
give a picture as to whether we thought
it was um uh we needed to make an
observation about the 60 million do and
whether we thought it would be
sufficient and we see plainly that the
60 million will not be sufficient and so
we're really here today to make that
observation and to really request
whether or not the $75 million that was
identified as a fiscal year um um
estimate or committed amount um will be
coming or not uh because if it's not
coming we need to make some adjustments
pretty darn quick actually pardon my
language um in terms of how we're going
to manage the claims the ones that are
scheduled and keep moving through
expeditiously and also how we're going
to keep operations in place so we have
we're both fully operational um and it
would be um unwise to dismantle those
operations so we would need to make sure
there was a sufficient amount in the 60
million if that is what our limit is
going to be and we'll we'll live with
whatever you give to us uh we'll need to
make sure there's a sufficient buffer to
keep our operations in place to get us
to the next fiscal year Appropriations
assuming those are coming so when you um
settle a claim and let's assume it's for
$100,000 can you settle do you settle it
that the $100,000
is paid right away or can it be paid
over you know $10,000 a year for 10
years so the statute as amended last
year uh for the first time gave the
administrator the discretion to
determine um according to factors by
Statute whether it would be a lump sum
paid in the first year paid Allin one um
or whether it would be paid in a term of
years periodic installments up to 10
years um and so the statute lays that
discretion to to the administrator um
and uh lays out factors to consider
about the claim in circumstances whether
it's Financial Health or otherwise um
The Lion's Share of awards that are um
provided that are given um once they're
verified um are periodic installments
and the table actually identifies shows
you a breakout of that if you'd like me
to walk you through that right so so
then you can stretch out the money you
have through to the end of the year here
no in this way
right
okay it's my understanding that these
projections account for um the the the
periodic installments uh that we're
currently doing and so therefore these
numbers would make the assumption that
even with periodic installments um the
$60 million would be insufficient I do
not know sitting here today
how long and how quickly what the pace
of the spend would be um but I'm
certainly watching it with our we have a
a financial um expert who's who's doing
that alongside us okay represent yeah
we'll start with representative leechman
then representative Griff thank you Mr
chairman and I'm looking at page three
um of the total resolve claims and I
noticed bullet number two it talks about
settlement with the interest without
interest so yes can you tell us what
you're providing for interest is that on
any claim that's being paid out over a
period of years or I'm assuming that's
what it is the dollar amount for the
interest itself well what the rate may
be um the statute that the legislature
adopted set a fixed rate of 5% 5% yep
and I guess I have another followup Mr
chairman so the the former Chief Justice
in his letter that we have says a
shortfall like you said is likely to
occur um no money was set aside for
fiscal 26 right there's no request
anywhere so once you're out of the 60
million uh for 25 you'd have to probably
come in for a special request before
fiscal but what about 26 and 27 because
we haven't seen any requests or any idea
what the settlement amount might be in
26 and 27 for any claims to the extent
that there is no request for 2026 and
2027 that is pending before the
legislature um U that would be a
surprise to us um and we would need to
know it in order to determine what to do
with the existing thousand claims that
we have pending and that are continuing
to come and be filed um on a weekly
basis that are expected to be filed all
the way through June
30th Mr chairman as you probably saw in
the chief former Chief Justice letter
because the statute gives me expressed
authority to approve payouts up to $75
million in claims in any fiscal year so
I assume he could come back to
fiscal U at the end of this fiscal year
and look for additional funds but that's
at least what he says in his
letter if you're expecting that request
for 2026 and 2027 to come directly from
the administrator I'll make sure to
report that to him um I think it was our
understanding that the statute itself um
specifically anticipate 75 million per
year um so if if we're misunderstanding
on that that's good for us to know I
believe it says up to yeah up to per
year per year right okay representative
Griffin thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh my question is
where there's a payment stretched over
time are you purchasing annuities to
fulfill that
payment are we is is the administrator's
office purchasing annuities to fulfill
the payment well TP typically on a suit
where there's payments over time many
times the an annuity with an insurance
company is purchased and the insurance
company
guarantees that that payment gets paid
over time and it's usually a cheaper um
you know there's usually a savings by
purchasing an annuity because the
insurance company is earning money on
the money before they have to pay it
out and I wonder whether you were using
that procedure or not it's a good
question um the Claims Administrator
administrator bradrick oversees the
claims process itself to see when a when
a claim comes in um and verifies it uh
for eligibility and then determines
whether there will be an award if it
goes through the resolution preceding
process at that point the administrator
Project's responsibilities concluded he
the claims in terms of being evaluated
and verified as to whether it will get
an award or not and what the payout is
concludes and then it goes into payment
processing and payment processing is
handled by the Attorney General's office
um he has the charge of the fund Itself
by Statute um and there's also a portion
under the statute that speaks to
structured settlements
and the responsibility that
administrator bradrick um has been given
um under the statute is to identify um
uh quality uh structured settlement
folks and put them on the website so
that they're available for for claimants
to go and decide if they want to pursue
a structured settlement road which I
imagine might be um addressing some of
of the U scenarios that you're that
you're identifying but the the
administrator does not have the
authority to compel someone um to seek
annuities or to seek a structured
settlement that is claimant's Choice
under the statute as written
representative
wer thank you did administrative brri or
anybody from the Department appear
before the governor or the or the
governor's uh budget director for the
preparation of the 2627 budget has the
administrator appeared in front of the
governor to discuss this
budget it is it's my understanding um
that the administrator has expressly
made himself available and and that but
it is not my understanding that such a
meeting has occurred yet but I would I
would need to bring that back to the
administrator to make sure that I have
up to the minute information on that so
from what he wrote to me he was never
consulted about this part of the budget
my understanding is that he's not been
consulted thank you represent evil
well I'm sure this is very difficult for
you to answer but it follows along with
the Chairman's um
questions many have observed that
there's no settlement money included in
the governor's draft of the budget
and would you have any idea why that
would be the
case I absolutely cannot speak on behalf
of the governor I know but I
just yeah well I just think it's worth
raising that it's an interesting fact
that there's nothing in there for the
$150
million so did I hear you say You have
about a thousand um requests for
settlements that that have not yet been
processed is that right well currently
we've have a a roughly over a thousand
claims that have been filed to date from
the beginning we have about 700 a little
bit over 700 claims that are actually
open and pending so but we have more
coming and we have a uh we are there's
about 25 law firms that are involved um
with the claims process they they all
don't have an equal amount of claim
claims obviously um and so we stay in
touch with the claims Council to get a
general sensus to how many may be coming
between now and and June 30th so that we
can plan um in a pretty fluid
environment we try to plan as best we
can um and so we do understand um that
there was a a commitment from at least
one of the uh significantly larger law
firms um during the last uh when the
statute was being amended last year that
they made a public commitment to bring
their uh this the claim the lawsuit
based claims bring them out of court and
bring them into their claims process um
so far we've seen that commitment
honored um and so really one of the
observations that is important for uh
that the administrator wanted to make
sure um I conveyed um today was if they
really the cost of not if the U if the
$75 million is not fully funded um what
is likely to happen throughout the
remainder of this fiscal year um it's uh
it's it's a destabilizing event um and
it it's a a loss of trust we've heard
that quite a bit from claims Council
that um if the money's not there then
that obviously means that we the
administrator can't spend Beyond 60
million your choice um and we will have
to take measures whether it's um
canceling
hearings um whether it's um slowing down
C the the the the the the tail end of
the life cycle of a claim um in order to
make sure we don't exceed the 60 million
that's our responsibility uh and we'd
need to do that in a way that we'd keep
operations open unless um we need to
account wasn't 100 million allocated in
fiscal year 24 yes it so over the bium
you've received 160 million right so
that's more than you would expect by 75
million a year in a banum the um we
received the statute as it came to us um
so when we opened operations in January
2023 the administrators
neutral um
independent um was not involved with the
statutory process and built the claims
process uh according to the statutory
Authority and the legal documents that
the legislature put in place for him to
follow and abide by and so through the
ordinary course of doing that um the100
million that was set aside in that um
initially
um did get awarded to um uh the
claimants and and we worked um side by
side with the Attorney General's office
to make sure that we did not go beyond
that 100 million and then when the
statute was being revised we were in the
what next
Waters okay um represent um is it a fair
statement that if um well in light of
the fact at this point there's no money
been put in the budget officially for
the claims to continue in the next dium
that the claimants could pursue their
cases in
court because many of them have
duplicate that that remains true so I
think when I think about the the cost of
not and and destabilizing a successful
system um one is that claims that are in
court right now may not come to us at
all um and the other is that the claims
that are with us now can be withdrawn um
they they claimants have a choice to
withdraw their claims um and I did want
to just put maybe a a little bit of a a
demographic point out there um out of
the approximately th000 claims um that
have been filed I think it's about
roughly
55% that um came from Superior Court I
could get some more a more accurate
number so we do re U receive quite a few
claims that have from law firms uh
representing claimants that have not
filed in court yet representative
W you mentioned 100 million went out in
claims my recollection
is a fairly uh major amount went out for
costs administrative costs people get
hired salaries and so on so you know it
wasn't the first 100 million didn't all
go out in claims the um yes you you are
correct um the quarterly reports that
are available on our website um has a
succinct page at the end of the corly
report that identifies um um our costs
um to give you a sense of that when we
brought these projections um as part of
the uh attachment a to the letter to the
attorney general um we estimate about 4
million a um a fiscal year that is joint
cost of both our office and the um
Attorney General's
office
okay
um all right um so of the 20 42 cases
that have been
closed um how many received no payment
no settlement no settlement um that's a
good question I would need to go back
and and look at those
numbers I mean that were basically found
to be
um invalid I guess I would have would
you like me to yes I'm curious and so
we've been told in general that we
expect I mean the the the deadline for
filing claims is the end of the fiscal
year I think is that right yes right and
we expect that overall there will have
been, 1500 claims does that still seem
about accurate I would agree with the
Attorney General on that yeah okay good
other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much okay um can I just add one
absolutely
um to the extent um the 75 million will
not be fully funded for this fiscal year
um I can't emphasize enough how
important it would be for us to know
that um to the the staff that we have um
we would need to make sure that we can
account for keeping um operations in
place from that 60 million and also
figure out how to make adjustments for
the awards all right so let me just say
you're in the wrong place to get another
15 million in fiscal year
2025 so the place to go is what's what
we call the fiscal committee and I think
the Attorney General can probably help
you with making a request to the fiscal
committee for 15 million whether they
Grant it or not I have no idea but thank
you okay appreciate the time today all
right you're welcome all right so I
think we're done for today and we'll be
back at 10: a.m. tomorrow for